merci d'avoir répondu à l'invitation
nous vous avons envoyé singulièrement
que je vous ai envoyé est ici les
représentants de différents syndicats de
la famille police nous le sénat et la
commission des lois est particulièrement
sensible sur les sujets à la fois de
sécurité et de justice
nous avons bien compris mais comme vous
mieux comme élus locaux aussi les
conditions dans lesquelles aujourd'hui
l'exercice du métier présente un grand
nombre de difficultés en particulier à
l'égard des actes de délinquance que je
qualifierais troalen de manière impropre
du quotidien qui sont de plus en plus
violent d'une part qui vous visent en
particulier bien sûr mais qui vise aussi
toute personne susceptible de ross de
représenter l'autorité publique je pense
aux sapeurs pompiers mais on peut penser
aussi évidemment aux élus locaux qui
sont de plus en plus en tous les cas
également victime de cette violence nous
avons tous regarder observer la
manifestation que vous avez organisé le
19 mai dernier devant l'assemblée
nationale
entendu les propos qui ont pu y être
tenu
naturellement à la fois dans les
conditions d'exercice je le rappelle de
votre mission
mais aussi les inquiétudes à l'encontre
de la réponse pénale dont posant de fait
la question des relations entre les
services de police et la justice
parfois dans des termes extrêmement fort
et j'ai considéré avec les collègues de
la commission des lois que ici devant la
représentation nationale officiellement
devant le parlement
il était important de pouvoir vous
entendre et d'organiser cette ce débat
et cette audition
nous sommes d'autant plus soucieux de
cela que non seulement ça traduit notre
volonté d' écoute mais nous avons un
texte qui arrivera au mois de septembre
qui est le texte confiance dans la
justice du gouvernement dont les
auditions et les rapporteurs ont été
désignés l'hôtel viendra donc je vous le
disais en septembre deuxième chose nous
avons été informés mais comme tout le
monde probablement par la télévision du
lancement des états généraux de la
justice
cet intéressant de savoir ce que vous
retenez de cette poule de cette démarche
et puis par ailleurs est présent ici
monsieur henri leroy commissaire de la
commission qui vit à participer au bout
de la sécurité en présentant
l'institution sénatoriales je ne veux
pas être plus longs pour conserver du
temps naturellement vous êtes nombreux
11 devoir vous exprimer cet après midi
on s'est donné deux heures d'horloge
pour être assez précis donc sans être
extrêmement directif
si on peut tenir les propos pour
faciliter aussi l'échangé avec les
collègues puisque les collègues
parlementaires sont des commissions sont
là d'autres probablement nous
rejoindrons mais il ya d'autres réunions
au même moment façon à ce qu'on puisse
avoir un échange fructueux sachant que
cette audition ne traduit qu'une partie
des discussions de la démarche que nous
aurons qui nous amènera sans doute soit
des textes mot soit ex de la rentrée
soit des prises de position du sénat
d'autres
d'une autre nature voilà ce que j'étais
vous dire l'important pour nous je le
redis devant la commission des lois
je me suis dans un lieu où on a le souci
permanent de la discussion et de la
vérité et donc nous sommes ravis que
vous ayez accepté de venir je crois
devoir quand même excusée officiellement
le syndicat unsa qui ne pouvait pas être
là cet après midi je le dis parce qu'ils
nous l'ont dit ils ont une réunion
fédérale où je crois et donc il n'y
avait pas de possibilité de venir
voilà j'ai été beaucoup trop long je
vais donner la parole à ceux qui
souhaitent débuter
soit vous étiez d'accord si vous n'êtes
pas mis d'accord soit je prends dans
l'ordre c'est comme vous le souhaitez
tout en vous demandant de vous présenter
à chaque fois pour qu'on puisse
l'identifier
les interlocuteurs monsieur et bien
merci messieurs les sénateurs mais
d'amener dessinatrice pour votre
initiative pour votre écoute on a
toujours une grande qualité d'écouté par
votre chambre
je commencerai au nom de la fédération
cfdt interco donc je suis accompagné du
fsi syndicat majoritaire des officiers
de police et d'alternatives policière
d'été qui est présent pour les gradés et
gardiens de la paix je commencerai mon
propos en soulignant le fait que un
grand travail d'inventaire et de
recensement des causes du malaise
policier avait été initiée par votre
homologue monsieur françois grosdidier
on est arrivé un document très riche
avec un diagnostic très précis
aujourd'hui malheureusement peu
d'évolution des quelques évolutions en
termes de moyens matériels aujourd'hui
le malaise est toujours aussi grand les
policiers malgré l'effort de recrutement
durant ce quinquennat sont toujours dans
une logique de priorisation des missions
ne sommes pas assez nombreux pour
effectuer
assurer le traitement de toutes les
missions donc ça mais parfois nos
collègues en insécurité juridique
en dehors des cas de conscience morale
que ça peut causer nous sommes toujours
nous croulons toujours sous une
procédure pénale a beaucoup trop
chronophage beaucoup trop axée sur les
droits des mis en cause et pas
suffisamment sur ceux des victimes
nous sommes sûrs ligne de crête sur
entre l'inquisitoire et la crise at war
ce qui rend notre travail très compliqué
aujourd'hui nous avons de ce fait une
crise des vocations pour les officiers
de police judiciaire
il ya quand même une réforme qui tend à
accélérer le déroulement de carrière des
officiers de police judiciaire du corps
d'encadrement et d'application je ne
suis pas certain qu'à long terme cela
soit totalement bénéfique puisque
aujourd'hui il ya une perte de sens du
travail de policier
nous faisons plus de l'abattage qu'un
traitement qualitatif des procédures
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis
déjà quelques années
nous demandons à ce qu'un travail de
simplification du code de procédure
pénale et de réécriture du code de
procédure pénale soit diligentée
conjointement avec les policiers et les
agents de justice et les magistrats
demandent un travail partenarial être
mettre fin à l'entretoit et voir les
choses de façon un peu plus haut q mais
nick et plus constructives et qui
demande un travail sur le long terme en
dehors des effets d annonce
le police bashing initié par quelques
responsables politiques je mets le mot
responsable entre guillemets ne cesse de
prospérer
donc voilà c'est nos collègues sont
vilipendés y sont lynchés suspect dans
la sphère privée
donc il ya quelques années la plupart
des fonctionnaires de police qui ne
pouvaient pas habiter sur leur
circonscription puisque travaillant dans
des agglomérations aux loyers
exorbitants donc le faisait le choix
contraint de travailler à une heure de
route de chez eux
et quand bien même ceux qui travaillent
dans des agglomérations des petites
villes de province aux loyers plus
accessible pourrait y habiter et bien
ils font le choix aujourd'hui de plus en
plus d'habiter à une heure de route de
chez eux
ça c'est une problématique que nous
demandons à nos dirigeants de traiter
alors il ya des partenariats qui ont été
engagées avec les la sncf sur les ter
pour les fonctionnaires de police afin
de sécuriser les lignes mais également
de prendre en charge le coût que peut
représenter le trajet travail domicile
pour les policiers mais peu sont
éligibles puisque beaucoup travaillent
en horaires décalés donc nous demandons
à ce qu'une réflexion soit engagée sur
la prise en charge des des péages sur
autoroutier sur le trajet travail
domicile et des policiers donc comme je
vous le dis ça représente quand même une
grosse part de leur budget mensuel des
dépenses mensuelles
donc voilà on demande quand
c'est un travail soit diligentée à ce
niveau là je vais pas monopoliser la
parole plus longtemps je vais céder la
parole à monsieur moreau donc chargé de
mission nationale pour le syndicat
syndicales et l'intérieur
tout à fait et donc je vais compléter
très rapidement le propos de julien donc
nous le csi est majoritaire au sein du
corps de commandement de la police
nationale je pense qu'effectivement il
ya un certain nombre de constats qui
sont faits depuis longtemps qui était
posée dans le rapport de 2018 qui sont
posées également dans le cadre du bureau
de la sécurité qui touchent notamment à
l'encadrement la formation je ne vais
pas refaire l'intégralité simplement
vous donner trois exemples récents déjà
sur le logiciel de rédaction des
procédures
on a un nouveau logiciel de rédaction
des procédures qui s'appelle scribe
c'est son nom qui a été annoncé par
l'ancien directeur général de la police
nationale en novembre 2017 c'était
monsieur morvan à l'époque c'est un
outil qui est utilisé par l'ensemble des
policiers au quotidien pour rédiger
leurs procès verbaux
notre logiciel actuel leur p3 est est
obsolète une ergonomie qui est
difficilement accessible et qui
complique le travail de nos collègues
ce logiciel scribe avait été annoncée en
2017 avec un objectif de déploiement
dans les services en 2019 bon sommes en
nous n'avons toujours pas de nouvelles
notre organisation a fait avait fait un
tract qui s'appelait scribe money
malheureusement on pourrait reprendre le
le trail esprits aujourd'hui puisque nos
collègues attendent ce logiciel qui doit
leur permettre de gagner du temps au
quotidien et pourtant malgré ce chantier
qui a été lancée en 2017 il ne voit
toujours rien venir
deuxième deuxième exemple en matière de
ressources humaines
si tout simplement les services de la
drc pn et l'ensemble des services de
ressources humaines étaient en capacité
avait suffisamment de moyens humains de
moyens informatiques pour fonctionner
correctement et garantir des mouvements
de mutation des arrêtés qui soit pris au
moment des prises d'échelon dans des
délais des sens dans mon esprit on
diminuerait déjà les risques
psychosociaux les fameux dont on parle
régulièrement pour pour parler de ce qui
concerne le corps de commandement notre
dernier mouvement général de mutation le
télégramme quel message vous savez qui
officialise les mutations et les
changements de poste est tombée le 30
avril pour une prise de poste qui était
théoriquement au 1er mai c'est à dire le
lendemain
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'administrations ou on se retrouve à
avoir une officialisation des mouvements
de mutations dans des délais aussi brefs
qui évidemment les spots temps à nos
collègues pour pour s'organiser pour
organiser leur vie familiale qui va avec
et dernier exemple dans la
revalorisation de la filière judiciaire
encore une fois je vais aborder un sujet
qui concerne aussi les officiers les
commissaires de police
aucune prime judiciaire il n'y a rien
qui valorise l'exercice au niveau de
l'encadrement on a fait lire jeudi sur
alors qu'on a également un problème
d'attractivité sur les postes
d'officiers et de commissaires dans les
services judiciaires qu'ils s'agissent
de commissariats ou des services de pgi
alors même que dans le même temps les
officiers de gendarmerie peu voient leur
qualité d'officier de police judiciaire
valoriser et l'exercice des missions
judiciaires valoriser donc une fois
encore on s'interroge sur le à parité
entre police nationale et gendarmerie
à ce niveau là pour ce qui est du projet
de loi justice on pourra y revenir dans
le dans le cadre de nos échanges nous
avons adressé un courrier à l'ensemble
des parlementaires après notre
rassemblement du 19 mai qui revenait sur
les dispositions qui nous inquiète c'est
le cas vous le savez de la présence de
l'avocat en perquisition qui est issue
d'un amendement adopté à l'assemblée
nationale nous espérons ainsi qu'à
l'issue du parcours législatif du texte
cette disposition ne sera plus ne sera
plus appliquée ne sera plus imposée aux
officiers de police judiciaire aux
magistrats parce qu'elle pose des des
questions y compris très pratiques de
sécurité par exemple comment va-t-on
assurer la sécurité de l'avocat de son
véhicule dans un certain nombre
d'endroits où nous sommes amenés à
perquisitionner où nous sommes équipés
avec des gilets pare balles avec les
policiers qu'on peut laisser pour garder
notre notre parc automobile
ça ne sera pas forcément le cas pour les
avocats donc ça pose énormément de
difficultés en plus de venir encore
alourdir la procédure pénale et les
contraintes qui pèsent à la fois sur les
enquêteurs et sur les magistrats
concernant l' enquête préliminaire on
s'interroge sur le devenir en fait au
bout des deux ans des enquêtes qui n'ont
pas pu être traités je pense aux
dossiers qui sont attribués un officier
de police judiciaire ou un enquêteur
dans un service qui va partir en
mutation qui malheureusement vu l'état
des ressources humaines ne voit pas
toujours être remplacé que vont devenir
ces dossiers qui n'ont pas pu être
présentés à un parquetier pour faire
l'objet d'une décision sur l'orientation
de la procédure
c'est vrai que ça nous pose ça nous pose
question
et sur les crédits de réduction de peine
pour ces quelque chose on est on est
évidemment assez favorable à ce que les
réductions de peine soit limitée par
rapport à ce qui a été possible pour
tous les agresseurs de personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
c'est quelque chose qui va dans le bon
sens mais dans le même temps ce projet
de loi envoie d'autres d'autres signaux
qui sont assez négatif je pense
notamment au fait en cour d'assises pour
entrer en voie de condamnation en
première instance d'être obligé de se
passer de six à sept voix sur neuf au
sein du jury
c'est quelque chose qui nous interpelle
et c'est vrai qu'on discute voilà on
nous a parfois accusé de poser
police et justice nous on pense qu'on
fait partie d'une même chaîne pénale on
discute notamment avec l'union syndicale
des magistrats quelle organisation
majoritaire chez les magistrats et c'est
des choses qui nous interpellent je
crois tous mais je veux pas être plus
long je répondrais si jamais il y avait
des questions sur ces points merci
monsieur oui je vais juste essayer de
compléter ce que je pense que
l'essentiel a déjà été énoncé peut-être
vous présenter s'il vous plaît moi je
vois votre nom mais pascal
je suis sûre international alternatif
police en charge de l'investigation du
renseignement c'est bon donc juste pour
pour poursuivre un petit peu rapidement
ce que mes collègues vient d'énoncer
donc en effet pour les objets ou les apg
en investigation un véritable problème
on constate une fuite de l'investigation
depuis des années une véritable
désaffection
on a également du mal à fidéliser les
collègues
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui on met en
investigation des sorties d'école alors
il faudrait des gens plutôt expérimenté
les droits de la défense qui ont été
systématiquement renforcée depuis une
vingtaine d'années n'ont pas été faits
en consultant les fonctionnaires de
police de base qui justement on va
traiter les procédures quotidien ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui la machine à les
bloquer certes les procédures ne sont
plus traitées on peut pas traiter on
doit prioriser les malheureusement les
procédures une grande partie n'est pas
traitée les magistrats se déplacent sud
dans les commissariats pour faire un tri
sélectif et donc ça ça nous pose un
véritable souci aujourd'hui donc les
droits de la défense renforcée également
par la présence de l'avocat en garde à
vue nous tout ce qu'on constate c'est
que 80% du temps de garde à vue c'est du
formalisme
on travaille véritablement 20% sur le
fond du dossier donc si on n'augmente
pas le temps des initiales de la garde à
vue
on ne sait pas comment un pouvoir
continuer à moi que les magistrats
reprennent des auditions par derrière
voilà ce que j'ai apporté je répondrai
aux autres questions plus particulière
et monsieur je vous propose que l'on
prenne une équipe des personnes qui sont
en visio c'est pas qui souhaitent
s'exprimer et monsieur qui lève la main
très bien l'asie
oui bonjour j'ai mon présence près des
réalités jeux de plissés faut alors une
question de forme sur la convocation à
ces travaux de la commission
j'appelle été laissé d'autre choix que
de participer d'une circonférence et on
réalise ce long avec la marrade ceux qui
sont présents ciel on comprend pas bien
mais ça n'est pas le plus important sur
le
[Musique]
les policiers ont pas bien notre
organisation représente essentiellement
voire exclusivement les gardiens et
gradés les 1,26 curité et les
personnalistes acquis techniques et
spécifiques
le moral n'est pas un l et vous nous
interroger sur les difficultés
rencontrées par les policiers dans leurs
missions
elles sont multiples d'abord un suicide
autorités à l'occasion de leur mission
était bafouée cabinet par des refus de
se soumettre aux contrôles aux
vérifications des refus d'obtempérer de
l' entrave à leur action n'a pas une
d'autres coupes home d'autres
vérifications sur la république des
outrages et violences volontaires et
malheureusement on a vécu récemment hu
pire ils sont aussi soumis à un stress
et une certaine précarité a le code de
déontologie et c'est bien normal et
aytré est très exigeant envers les
policiers de ce fait c'est sûr par les
corporations qui est soumise le plus de
solutions disciplinaire pour d'autres
raisons c'est sûrement aussi une des
corporations qui est soumise action
d'injustice il s'est soumis à des
violences sont soumis à ces violences
sont en service
ils sont soumis à ces violences hors
service peu et leur poche ils sont
soumis à des violences dans les services
et ça ça fait aussi partie pas
occupation socialement on a tendance à
nous dire que c'est le métier qui veut
ça mais les collègues sont soumis à des
charges de travail assez importante tout
ça à des horaires atypiques un fluctuant
mouvant il n'y a pas de sanctuarisation
de leur temps de repos que ce soit les
week-ends et rocco de cycle quand il
s'agit le collègue âge il suffit qu il
ya 2
sans autorisation de leur forme congés
puisqu'on avait un dispositif notre
prévisionnel de congé qui marche et aux
moyens investis via e mail
opérationnalité n'en a pas les plus en
plus difficile pour nos collègues
d'avoir des perspectives sur leur compte
l'avenir et du moment estimation à
partager en famille ou entre amis voilà
ça dans une absence quasi sens comme à
égal quasi systématique de soutien dans
leurs services au sein de l'institution
voilà un peu aussi en dehors de la
mission de la confrontation
actuellement ce et karité d'abord bezu
dollar action un peu conduire les
policiers dans l'état d'esprit qu'elle
je laisserais ya une bastia qui
m'accompagne pour faire rapidement un
petit topo sur le projet de loi pour la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
juste de vous avez vous allez aussi
interrogé sur oger de d'état janeiro la
justice elle va nous l'ont la paix ni
nos voeux valium secrétaire général mais
bobby joueront à partager deux tribunes
dans la presse avec la secrétaire
général d'unité magistrat force ouvrière
pour appeler à la tenue de ces états
généraux ya clairement un problème à un
os de réponse pénale notamment c'est ce
qui nous concerne au premier chef
en termes de réponse pénale à l'égard
des les auteurs d'infraction envers les
policiers
donc il faut qu'on trouve des solutions
pour qu'on avance sur ce terrain là et
puis plus globalement réussie avec
l'évolution de la justice
là où il ya trop con d'aménagement de
peine était d'exception et
l'emprisonnement était la règle pour les
délits ou crimes l on réalise que
maintenant en fonctionnement n'est que
l'exception et l'aménagement de peine
avec ça c'est l'effet de dispositions
accumulée notamment celle de m
p mais il faut vraiment qu'on revienne à
quelque chose de plus efficient l'on
fait un constat la sanction pénale a
vocation à unir à réparer et cerise sur
le gâteau à
heureux se réinsérer et sauteurs
d'infraction dans le constat qu'on fait
c'est qu'elle rappelait la soupe super
dan curieux aucune de ces trois tâches
donc il ya sans doute un problème de
moyens on entend même les héros sont ce
qu'ils sont alors sans doute que la
justice et d'autres moyens notamment à
nice pâti au travers des greffiers du
reste sans doute que les moyens de la
justice doit peut-être d'améliorer
doivent être amplifiées en attendant ça
on n'a aucune garantie que ça puisse
arriver dans des délais assez brefs donc
moscou mais ouais c'est la justice elle
soit un peu plus chirurgicale on sent
commandes qui est un débat public sur ce
que la société ne peut plus les
féminicides les a fait un peu policiers
les atteintes aux personnes dépositaires
de l'autorité publique de manière
générale et que foot ces infractions
elles soient ciblés par la justice de
manière systématique pour qu'on s'en
sorte et qu'on passe aux infractions
suivante voilà bon je vais laisser la
parole à la liane vestiaire pour ce qui
concerne le projet de loi pour la
migration de l'institution judiciaire en
ce moment merci monsieur peut-être avant
que votre collègue interviennent vous
dire simplement que la distinction entre
ceux qui sont en présentiel et ceux qui
sont en visio répondent aux conditions
de jauge que l'on doit respecter au sein
d'institutions sénatoriales avant elle
sait pas comment les choses se sont
organisés en temps entre les uns et les
autres mais sachez qu'en aucun cas il
n'y a plus d'importance pour les uns ou
pour les autres ou moins d'importance
pour les uns ou pour les autres et que
nous entendons bien ce que vous dites en
plus long temps fort et clair parce que
le son marche très très bien et on vous
voit parfaitement
donc ne vous inquiétez pas là dessus et
puis y aura d'autres occasions de venir
au sénat j'imagine messieurs je me suis
reconnu coupable
bonjour monsieur albert tir de l'ailier
national en charge de l'investigation
police donc je vais me reposer en tout
cas sur la loi confiance dans
l'institution policière projet de loi et
l étudier dernièrement à l'assemblée
nationale et qui arrivent comme voulait
le préciser à l'étude au sénat très
prochainement alors vous n'aviez orienté
sur sur certains articles l'article 2
sur la réforme de la têt lunaire c'est
pas reprendre par des propos de me
coller deux précédentes pour lesquelles
nous sommes totalement d'accord là qui
peut bien sûr les remises de peine
là c'est un peu plus que ça dépend même
si on vient nous nous l'expliqué la
tentation de la haine nous importe
beaucoup sur ces remises de peine et sur
la juridiction elle en espère bien que
ses skis ce poisson oeuvre mais là on
voit donc avec quelques petites remises
de peine c'est très à la marge
ce qui nous importe aussi beaucoup c'est
qu'une partie de l'article 3
effectivement avec l'amendement 814 qui
n'était initialement pas dans ce projet
de loi et on y voir des membres et dans
les nombreux articles de ce projet de
loi on y va des van loo défiance envers
les enquêteurs c'est ce qui ressort des
premières remontées le terrain mais
qu'est ce qu'on veut nous le répétons
nous souhaitons tous nous sommes décidés
leurs enseignants et les enquêteurs du
corps d'encadrement et d'application
sont le gros des troupes
aujourd'hui c'est eux qui hier c'était
bien une tare pen qui interpelle 8 et
qui en quête de moins en moins je
reprends mon collègue 80% des actes
d'une procédure sont des actes de forme
au quotidien dans l'aisne 15 de femmes
de délinquance de masse donc ça il faut
il faut lui couper un remède et
notamment dans dans le cadre d'une
réforme de la procédure pénale
ce n'est pas ce qu'on est en train de
voir dans ce projet de loi dans
l'arctique de confiance dans l'édition
d'hier
cette présence de l'avocat en
perquisition sur un acte qui est déjà
initialement très chronophage
déplacements à l'extérieur des monts
police se projeter à plusieurs
kilomètres et ensuite l'arrivée de
l'avocat mais lorsqu'on parle de la
forme la scène sans fil en afrique
rappaz nous avons des nous sommes
entretenus des nains dernièrement avec
le directeur de la police judiciaire de
l'été monsieur sacchi nous donner des
exemples avec des procédures puisque
c'est normal qu'ils soient déjà en
suisse avec des procédés une
perquisition qui peuvent durer
il y en avait une qui était encore un
peu plus de 36 heures donc lorsqu'on est
sur des délais sur des délais contraints
de la garde à vue je reprends sur 48 ans
de carla d'imaginer le vix que c'est un
peu ça qu à une partition en matière de
stupéfiants cirque on est sur des 87 eur
garde à vue n'est pas quoi en beaucoup
de temps s'il va rester effectivement
hollande qui a fait de même pendant ce
délai de garabit cela nous inquiète
hélas en moins
l'anem la méfiance en plus de la
conduite ification de nombreux éléments
sur cette recette pestis bien bien nous
on sait que le futur de l'enquêteur sera
de plus en plus compliqué et pour
reprendre les propres déjà évoqué la
crise des vocations dans cette filière
qui est très marquants de ces dernières
années avec une réforme qui n'aboutira
pas n'aboutira pas les pistes des pistes
explorées actuellement par notre
administration ne sont certainement pas
les douanes le bcs y vient de parler
d'un réclamer une prime d'encadrement
judiciaire j'ose même pas quand même pas
vous parler de l'augmentation de 18
euros dont vont bénéficier peut-être
passé au 1er janvier
le dollar était meilleur a publié les
enquêteurs savent très bien tout le
monde rires jaunes certes mais ça fait
rire tout le monde
donc messieurs les sénateurs on pouvait
entendre qu'il ya dans la prière
investigations bien eu lieu une somme
qui pourrait finalement mené à une perte
une perte de confiance j'ai aussi dans
l'institution judiciaire si aujourd'hui
et là on revient sur les étages et une
rebelle justice une prise en compte
d'une procédure pénale totalement
obsolète avec des grilles qui sont
empilées les unes après les autres c'est
si l'amendement 814 santé en est une de
plus
si aucune prise en compte rapide de
cette procédure pénale
hors d'âge ne vient pas ne vient pas sur
le devant de la scène le l'avenir de la
destination de la police nationale et
plus que sont donc c'est vrai que nous
appelons de nos voeux une étude d'impact
de ces réformes sur le terrain plutôt
que des doses quotidiennes cet article
de puissance et un moment ils sont 14
il va vous arriver monsieur
l'ex-sénateur habitudes toutes ont pâti
de la plus grande importance même si sur
un joueur sait si je me suis 2022 cette
proposition était venu gros ans
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui elle vient chez
vous ça fait que dans les rangs de
descente étant la police nationale c'est
extrêmement mal perçu du badhus tech
jusqu'au bout du spectre
parce que c'est tellement chronophage
déjà quand même vous dire là que l'acte
de perquisitions s'il venait encore à se
complexifier ont beaucoup se demandent
comment fera demain voilà pour les
premiers points que vous voulez nous
apporter merci monsieur
on va revenir
représentants des syndicats qui sont pas
en présentiel peut-être madame merci
monsieur linda bouquet conseiller
technique
synergie officiers je suis aujourd'hui
accompagné de benjamin je lis sécrétaire
national
je vais essayer de ne pas être redondant
puisqu'un certain nombre de choses ont
d'ores et déjà été dit et et précisé
mais j'aimerais revenir néanmoins
effectivement sur un point précis à
savoir le climat véritablement délétère
dans lequel nos collègues travaillent
quotidiennement un climat de violence il
ne se passe pas un jour sans qu'il y ait
un fait un événement qui défraie la
chronique tout le monde malheureusement
on fait le constat mais rien au change
nous pensons réellement que la plus
grande difficulté c'est qu'il n'ya pas
effectivement de reconnaissance de
l'autorité des forces de police et ce en
raison finalement d'une réponse pénale
qui n'est pas assez efficace en tout cas
pertinente
à tel point qu'on a un phénomène
véritablement un sentiment
d'incompréhension au sein des rangs de
la police nationale lorsque des
enquêteurs s'investissent au cours d'une
enquête judiciaire
identifie les auteurs notamment de
violences policières réussi réussissent
pardon à les interpeller et que
finalement la réponse pénale n'est pas à
la hauteur fil des faits en tout cas
constatés et relevés je fais pas le
parallèle pardon avec les états généraux
effectivement de la justice pour
l'instant on ne peut pas en dire ce
qu'il en ressortira mais on en appelle
de tous nos voeux à une célérité et à
une sévérité de la justice notamment
pour ce type de faits le deuxième point
sur lequel j'aimerais également insisté
on en a beaucoup parlé
déjà c'est effectivement cette crise du
judiciaire qui ne suscite plus
aujourd'hui de vocation un certain
nombre de projets ont vu en tout cas ont
été proposées notamment en termes de
simplification de la procédure pénale
mais là encore ce n'est pas à la hauteur
des attentes des policiers je vais vous
donner un exemple un certain nombre de
circonscriptions au sein la préfecture
de police vont être site pilote
quant au projet de réalisation d'une
partie de la procédure pénale notamment
sur la garde à vue qui effectivement
beaucoup de beaucoup de fort qui
nécessite en tout cas un certain nombre
de formalisme et assez chronophage pour
l' enquête et on se rend compte
finalement que ce projet encore une fois
à voir ce qu'il donne dans les faits
mais on a déjà beaucoup d'à priori
puisqu'il s'agira finalement de lire à
l'interpeller ses droits donc ces trois
pages à lire enregistré ce avec un cd
qui devrait être placé sous scellés donc
au final le gain de temps
né est inexistant donc on s'inquiète
véritablement là aussi et on les
policiers je pense on droit au chapitre
ont voix au chapitre en tout cas à faire
un certain nombre de propositions pour
simplifier aujourd'hui leur quotidien
notamment dans le domaine judiciaire
monsieur non travers passez votre tour
alors en visioconférence je vois un bras
qui s'est levé allez-y monsieur oui
alors frédéric lagache délégué général
allianz accompagne et de stanislas
goudron qui prendra la parole juste
après après un luminaire très rapide un
deux de trois minutes sur la difficulté
rencontrée l'événement par les policiers
que vous connaissez aussi bien que nous
puisque bon ça a été rappelé tout à
l'heure il ya eu plusieurs bons
commission sur le sujet qui ont rappelé
ses difficultés à la menace terroriste
la pression migratoire la radicalisation
des mouvements sociaux auxquels on peut
rajouter
l'application des règles sanitaires et
parler également parce que ça a été dit
de l'augmentation d'aller de la
délinquance bon cette pression a conduit
depuis plusieurs années à une
augmentation on le sait tous et vous le
savez également des heures
supplémentaires ça a conduit aussi à une
hyper vigilance de nos collègues qui a
amené un épuisement aussi de l'ensemble
des forces de l'ordre et il y à noter
aussi que cette pression a eu pour
conséquence cette idiotie donc je vais
aller assez vite que nous sommes devenus
les cibles de tous les acteurs qui
veulent qu'ils ne veulent plus voir tout
simplement les forces de l'ordre dans ce
pays
aujourd'hui le self et d'incarner
l'autorité quelqu'un soit vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le sénateur qu'on peut
être policier on peut être élu on peut
être aujourd'hui instit
on peut être pompier bon nous incarnons
tous à toutes et tous l'autorité et le
fait de l'incarner suffit à lui seul
d'être la cible la cible de la
délinquance au quotidien on le voit tous
les jours on la cible aussi des
terroristes on le sait pertinemment avec
toutes les affaires dramatiques que nous
avons pu vivre la cible est là aussi de
certains forte heureusement pas une
majorité certains hommes politiques
certaines femmes peu importe de
certaines associations de certains
journaliste au point qu'aujourd'hui
policiers c'est pas nouveau mais s'est
renforcée il doit se cacher de on va
dire de sa fonction afin d'être fins
d'éviter d'être d'être visés dans le
cadre de sa vie tout simplement
citoyenne il doit se protéger lui-même
mais il doit aussi protéger sa famille
je le rappelais tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui pas un policier peut dire
que fera ses enfants peuvent dire
l'école qui sont des enfants de deux
pères ou mères de policiers au point que
systématiquement il est visé je
terminerai mon en liminaire mes propos
que comme j'ai dit teneur que stan va
poursuivre aujourd'hui si on veut faire
diminuer la délinquance je crois que
c'était les propos de notre
manifestation intersyndicale et vous
l'avez rappelé ou quand même en peu de
temps je crois que c'est en une semaine
35000 personnes qu'on se soit policier
aux citoyens se sont rassemblés
il ya plusieurs facteurs qui s'en seront
essentiels c'est qu' il faut une
cohérence et que ça a été rappelé lors
de cette manifestation et vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure je pense qu'il faut
une cohérence entre l'action du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est à dire
nos collègues tous les jours ce qui
identifie les délinquants qui rassemble
les preuves et ensuite qui présente ces
individus aux magistrats et vous doutez
bien où je veux en venir
et le ministère de la justice
ce qu'ils vont faire appliquer la loi et
dès lors où les faits sont constitués on
note quand même parfois est très souvent
par ailleurs bon une incompréhension par
rapport à l'application de la loi qui a
valu l'objet de cette manifestation et
qui a fait l'unanimité dans le cadre de
des syndicats de police et
d'administratifs par ailleurs et qui a
fait que nous étions nombreux et aussi
on va dire compris de la population
puisque derrière tout ça
asson un sondage on ne peut pas on va
dire dire qu'il a pu être manipulée par
une quelconque organisation syndicale
bon a dit que les citoyens de ce pays
relais plus confiance en leurs polices
quand leur justice donc a longtemps
donné lorsque la démocratie s'exprime je
pense qu'il ya des choix à faire et des
choses à dire
ensuite il faut dans ses attendus bien
évidemment mais s'était rappelée mais je
ne peux pas rentrer dans le détail tout
à l'heure peut-être des policiers
motivés ont aussi bien par leur pouvoir
d'achat direct ou leur pouvoir d'achat
direct parce que je vais résumer ça
comment peut-on vivre décemment et
appréhender notre métier sereinement
avec 2000 euros par mois dans une ville
on pourrait citer de nombreuses villes
de province où il faut aller chercher
des loyers à 1200 ce qui reste 800 euros
pour pouvoir faire le reste
je suis pas persuadé ni vous ni moi qui
suis en fin de carrière mais un début de
carrière pourrions assumer une carrière
et appréhender le métier on va dire
sereinement et je terminerai aussi par
des conditions qui sont importantes et
ça fera l'objet je pense que
d'interrogations
au delà d'une action cohérente entre
ministère de l'intérieur et le ministère
de la justice que sont des textes on va
dire et des règlements et des lois
adaptées
je pas revenir sur l'actualité en ce
moment des rodéos loi sur les rodéos la
procédure pénale ça fait puis je suis
syndicaliste presque qu'on entend parler
de l'aménagement l'allègement pardon de
la procédure pénale
donc enfin nos collègues antique 8
heures passent plus de temps on va dire
à enquêter que à faire de la paperasse
donc ça a été dit je me rappelle
certaines manifestations où nous avait
promis monts et merveilles sont
l'allégement de la procédure pénale
je me rappelle une dernière d'ailleurs
c'était à place vendôme lieu aussi
symbolique n'a pas par ailleurs appelé à
autant polémique
notre dernière manifestation mais qui
était aussi symbolique sur le choix et
pour en arriver aujourd'hui un
alourdissement de la procédure pénale
un moment donné je crois que les choses
sont dit mais les jaunes ce ne sont
jamais fait ou peu fait et pour terminer
par une loi qui était sur la sécurité
globale quand on parle de la difficulté
du métier et que le policier peut être
la cible et on l'a vu dans le cadre des
attentats terroristes
bon c'est le floutage l'anonymisation du
policier dans le cadre de ses missions
chose que tout à chacun on a pu évoquer
à multiples reprises dans les
différentes munitions qu'elle soit à
l'assemblée nationale qu'elle soit au
sénat
et malheureusement parfois peu entendu
même si sur le coup on nous dit souvent
en aparté bien évidemment que nous avons
raison bon voila un petit peu rapidement
sur le linéaire et je vais laisser la
parole si vous me permettez bien
évidemment à stan guesdon sur l'ailé
l'ensemble de ces aspects que j'ai
balayé assez rapidement très bien merci
oui alors je souhaiterais en fait évoqué
deux sujets évidemment dans les
difficultés au quotidien dans l'exercice
des missions vous l'aurez compris est
dans la bouche de syndicalistes si on
parlait pas des conditions de travail et
notamment des moyens qui sont alloués
aux forces de sécurité et bien il
faudrait qu'on change effectivement deux
mandats alors je tiens à rappeler que le
budget de la police nationale c'est un
budget déséquilibré vous le savez 90% de
masse salariale et qui s'est faite aux
fêtes au je dirai au détriment en fait
de l'investissement et du fonctionnement
qui n'ont perdu juste que 130 millions
d'euros en l'espace de trois ans ce
n'est pas rien parce que combien de
voitures en moins combien de rénovation
immobilière au moins combien
d'ordinateurs en moins et tous ces
éléments là font que au quotidien du
coup le policier se retrouvent entravé
parce que passer d'ordinateur parce que
des véhicules qui ont dépassé le nombre
le kilométrage par rapport au
renouvellement de l'immobilier qui tombe
en décrépitude et quand vous accueillez
des victimes quand vous travaillez 365
jours dans un quotidien qui est
complètement délabré croyez-moi ce n'est
pas facile
donc il faudra effectivement revenir sur
ce budget de la police nationale c'est
un élément important
je mettrai de côté le budget 2021 qui a
été mis en fait sous perfusion grâce au
plan de relance
j'ose espérer que 2022 ne fera pas
partie des budgets qui seront en baisse
encore pire par rapport aux ceux qui ont
précédé et que vraiment on aura mis un
peu d'ambition dans les moyens alloués
aux forces de sécurité et enfin l'autre
moyen dans des conditions de vie et de
travail des policiers
ça a été évoqué à plusieurs plusieurs
interlocuteurs les moyens réglementaires
juridiques souvent il ya des efforts qui
sont faits pour écrire des textes mais
souvent ces textes sont entravés alors
parfois par un exercice parlementaire de
la navette
parfois par des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
parfois le conseil d'état qui nous met
un coup d'arrêt sur certaines
dispositions intéressantes pour les
collègues
je pense par exemple à l'engagement pour
les forces mobiles pour les collègues
qui sont en maintien d'ordre
je pense aux décisions
constitutionnelles par rapport à la
protection des policiers lorsque leur
visage est diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux
je trouve que il faudrait vraiment qu'on
ait l'ambition d'aller jusqu'au bout
pour réellement donner les moyens
juridiques et réglementaires aux
policiers de pouvoir exercer sereinement
leur quotidien si tout le monde a dit le
policier va mal dans son quotidien
il a malgré tout cette super motivation
pour protéger les personnes et les biens
pour parfois faire des heures
supplémentaires tous les jours être
rappelé le week-end mais il n'empêche
que au bout du bout c'est lui qui est en
souffrance parce que il a l'impression
d'avoir cette perte de sens du métier je
reviendrai pas sur la procédure pénale
ça a été longuement évoquée il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
beaucoup de choses qui ont été annoncées
qui n'ont pas été faites je pense à
toute la partie numérique
je m'interroge d'ailleurs sur un certain
budget qui nous avait pris quand même
pas loin de plus de 100 millions d'euros
pour faire la direction du numérique
quand on voit que le logiciel scribe
n'est toujours pas je dirais efficace et
opérationnel dans les rangs de
l'investigation
il ya quand même des questions à se
poser sur les moyens qui sont allés aux
forces de sécurité
enfin dernier élément et pas des
moindres c'est la chaîne pénale
alors si effectivement les policiers
et travaille bien avec les magistrats
dans le cadre des enquêtes
quel que soit d'ailleurs les cadres
denquête sur la réponse pénale et le
bout de la chaîne pénale et bien je vous
invite à regarder un tableau qui
d'ailleurs fait partie d'un rapport du
sénat sur la loi sécurité globale ou sur
trois ans il a été fait état de toutes
les agressions à l'encontre des
policiers donc des personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique des
fonctionnaires exerçant des missions de
service public et des sapeurs pompiers
et quand vous regardez les taux
d'emprisonnement prononcée sur trois ans
quand vous regardez les quantum de peine
qui sont prononcés eh bien je rejoindrai
le verdict du sénat qui a dit que on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya un fossé entre les
peines encourues et les peines
prononcées et je vous parle même pas des
peines exécutées parce que là ça irait
encore beaucoup trop loin dans je le
dirai ce constat qui fait que à la fois
les policiers ne comprennent pas cette
chaîne pénale comprennent pas
l'aboutissement de leur travail et aussi
parce qu'il faut le rappeler les
citoyens qui ne comprennent pas et qui
du coup je rappelle moins d'un français
sur deux fait confiance en la justice
une fois qu'on a fait ce diagnostique je
crois qu'il faudra vraiment on ait le
courage de donner je dirais une
impulsion parce que si effectivement
tout le monde sera d'accord sur la
séparation des pouvoirs
il n'empêche que la politique pénale
elle se conduit l s'instruit health
impulse et seul le garde des sceaux peut
le faire ça peut se faire en corrélation
avec les policiers
certes c'est parfois on nous a reproché
de pas donner de tous les éléments dans
les enquêtes
mais si on donne pas tous les moyens aux
policiers de mener des enquêtes et bien
les taux d'élucidation effectivement
peuvent être compliqué à gérer
donc je crois que cette chaîne pénale
dans sa globalité
il faudra qu'elle soit prise en compte
par l'ensemble des acteurs et vous
législateur vous êtes un des acteurs qui
peuvent nous aider et nous vous en
remercions si vous avez effectivement
cette volonté de nous aider dans
l'écriture de ses textes est si
important dans la navette parlementaire
merci monsieur je recherchais que la
commission des lois a beaucoup de
regrets sur le texte ce qui a été global
même s'il s'est beaucoup investi pour
rédiger un certain nombre d'articles
alors qu'est-ce qui reste qui ne s'est
pas exprimé monsieur mais grève droit
c'est ça
allez-y monsieur on vous entend pas là
vous m'entendez mieux ça marche très
bien et est très bien revenue me
représenter je vous présente les
commissaires de police le syndicat
indépendant des commissaires de police
travaillant
merci je vais être le plus court
possible et essayer de pas être
longtemps avec ce qu'ils ont ce qu'ont
pu dire les représentants des autres
associations puis s'il ya des des
associations professionnelles puisque de
toute façon
malheureusement sur ce sujet nous sommes
tous unanimes aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une crise profonde de la police
nationale qui ne fait que répondre à une
crise profonde de la société française
qui aujourd'hui subi énormément de
violence qui aujourd'hui constate que
ces violences sont de plus en plus
graves qui constate également que ceux
qui les commettent bénéficie au delà de
l'excusé de l'impunité la plus totale et
une société qui s'inquiètent nous sommes
aux première loges et nous sommes ceux
qui si vous me permettez l'expression
contribué à en prendre le plus au
quotidien plein la tête
je m'explique nous avons manifesté il ya
pas longtemps suite à des évènements
plus que dramatique ou de nos collègues
dans deux endroits différents avait été
lâchement assassinés
nous avions déjà manifestés il y à
quelques quelques temps pour signaler qu
on avait des grosses difficultés
la réponse au delà du petit bâle
médiatique du gouvernement elle est
inexistante
elle est inexistante parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est coincé avec un
certain nombre de principes été rappelé
qu' on ne peut rien demander à la
justice et que la justice n'a pas à
rendre des comptes ni à la communauté
nationale ni aux élus ni à son ministre
donc on a une grosse difficulté et de
l'autre côté on a les policiers qui sont
régulièrement attaqués leurs familles
qui sont régulièrement stigmatisée on a
été amené ces dernières années à
développer aussi des plans pour lutter
contre les suicides qui se multipliaient
de notre institution ce n'est pas un
hasard
aujourd'hui la situation elle est grave
mais elle serait presque
enfin il pourrait faire sourire si on ne
s'était pas si grave si on faisait le
comparatif avec cette fameuse
manifestation ou le jour même où on
expliquer quelles étaient les
difficultés de nos métiers on avait tout
un tas de gens qui seront venus on a eu
du citoyen lambda mais on a eu aussi les
élus qui sont venues des parlementaires
de tous bords j'insiste là dessus de
tous bords et en même temps le soir même
on a voté des dispositions pour entraver
nono mission je pense à la disposition
sur la perquisition
mais au delà de l' entrave à nos
missions ce sont des des dispositions
qui ont été votées qui qui souligne la
méfiance vis-à-vis de l'action des
forces de l'ordre
parce que faire participer un avocat à
une perquisition perquisition qui est
déjà soumise à un certain nombre de
règles de forme s'est estimé
qu'aujourd'hui les policiers les
gendarmes qui les mène au quotidien font
n'importe quoi ou sont liberticides
donc c'est une façon de reprendre d'une
main ce qu'on essayait symboliquement de
nos données d'une autre quand ont
manifesté à nos côtés et là on a une
grosse difficulté et vous savez tous
malheureusement que même si les travaux
éclairé de votre commission au sénat
essaye de d'en édulcorer un certain
nombre de conséquences funestes ce genre
de réforme au nom des libertés
conservera toujours quelque chose
or ce quelque chose aujourd'hui est
devenu totalement insupportable pour
ceux qui sont chargés de faire respecter
la loi et les règlements dans ce pays
on le voit tous les jours sur les
chaînes d'information on est amené à
faire respecter tout un tas de
prescription y compris des couvre feux
et autres divers et variés et et notre
action est la plus de sens et notre
action elle n'est pas capable
aujourd'hui d'être confirmée par l'étape
suivante de la chaîne pénale et on a une
attitude
on demande régulièrement se réformer
quand on demande de réformer une
institution c'est qu'on estime qu'elle
n'est pas assez efficace si on a toutes
les institutions autour qui ne sont
jamais réformé et qui ne s'intéresse
jamais sur leur utilité réelle au
service de la population
donc malheureusement on a un gros sujet
ce sujet aujourd'hui il est portée du
gardien de la paix au chef des deux
services aux directeurs centraux
c'est quelque chose qui fait sens ça
veut dire que c'est pas juste du
corporatisme
c'est un vrai sentiment d'abandon de la
part des pouvoirs publics
voilà je vous remercie merci monsieur ya
pas qu il y a plus d'autres intervenants
je crois merci on va laisser la parole
aux collègues qui souhaitent s'exprimer
mais si je peux me permettre une deux
questions sur le point particulier des
perquisitions
est ce que nous avons est ce qu'il
existe un certain nombre de statistiques
sur des procédures qui aurait été
annulée du fait d'un problème de
légalité des perquisitions
est-ce qu'on a des chiffres là dessus
parce que la question et d'un port afin
la question peut avoir un intérêt de
savoir qu'un la fin je la présence d'un
avocat
au cours de la perquisition on peut lui
donner un sens ou pas de sens vraiment
plus zen un sens mais le premier élément
pour savoir si les choses se passent
voilà bien ce qui paraît simplement dans
90% des cas est le cas les choses se
passent bien
est ce qu'on a déjà eu des recours face
à des actes des perquisitions qui ont
entré entraîner des nullités de
procédure auquel cas qui auraient montré
c'est ce que là où je veux dire que le
la perquisition n'aurait pas respecté
les règles
ce qu'on a cet élément-là d'appréciation
qualitative du coup quelqu'un lève la
main allez y et les i dernière
la présence dans la dans les
possibilités de l'en-tête la présence
d'une mise en cause du titulaire du
logement de meilleur dans d'autres cas
sont des représentants légaux qui
peuvent dès à présent les parents et
l'homme est en en bout de course quand
il n'y a plus d'autre choix deux témoins
qui font pas des fonctionnaires de
police qui sont pris au hasard des
voisins des passants ça m'est arrivé de
prendre des passants dans la rue gloire
demandé s'il voulait bien assisté pour
procéder à la perquisition
donc on se regardait déjà de nombreuses
formes et de garanties de garanties
quant au voile à la légalité et est une
bonne chose
une bonne pratique faite par exemple j
quand vous parlez de défiance cet
amendement va exactement dans ce sens
c'est à dire qu' ils répondent pas aux
questions pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on
attend à l'église de procédure alors
peut-être quelques tables et quelques
derniers peuvent être enceinte mais là
non plus ne sont pas des médias sur les
réseaux sociaux certains se félicitent
de certains membres comme ça on arrêtera
de voir des découpes on pourrait
l'orienter les canapés est possible sur
place
l'individuel pur et parce qu'ensuite il
a assisté par son avocat dans le gamin
sa garde à vue pourrait dénoncer de tels
comportements donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est cet amendement qui
vient qui vient nous nous cachons pas
que sur le haut du spectre et dans
certaines dans certaines formes
d'infractions ne vient pour que pour
mettre certaines choses lorsque je vous
parle de six façons de celui-ci passé la
semaine dernière où on va re la craie
sur une partition certainement sur des
affaires très important le concert qu'il
y avait sur place plus d'avocats et
d'enquêteurs s'est quand même c'est
quand même assez roulant sylvain
marveaux l'on voit la chine
merci de cette précision je crois que
monsieur mais grève est levé la main me
semble-t-il puis pas de bêtises et ici
c'est pour ces pour confirmer ce qui
vient d'être dit et puis pour donner un
autre éclairage - istres que je
travaille actuellement au police
judiciaire effectivement il ya un
certain nombre de conditions de forme on
a cité celle de base qui est la présence
d'officiers de police judiciaire
on n'est pas officier de police
judiciaire si on n'a pas été formés si
on n'a pas subi un examen qui pour
lesquelles on a un certain nombre de
magistrats qui s'engage on a des
questions de forme y compris des
questions d'horaires puisqu'on ne fait
pas de perquisition la nuit sauf
autorisation spéciale d'un magistrat du
siège
mais il faut savoir quand même que par
delà les exemples un peu pittoresque de
la suisse qui est actuellement mis en
lumière aucun pays au monde ne
pratiquent la présence de l'avocat en
perquisition pas même le pays des
avocats
c'est à dire les états unis d'amérique
où pourtant les avocats sont extrêmement
puissants mais on est là on n'aurait pas
l'idée de faire participer à un acte
d'investigation un représentant d'une
des parties parce que si on commence
comme ça on va essayer de faire
participer aussi le représentant du
parti ça va être un happening générale
pour savoir quand il faut quand il faut
être présent et puis surtout les
perquisitions
elles se passent aussi très tôt le matin
en retrait pour le matin à 6 heures du
matin je doute de la présence effective
d'un certain nombre de jours et donc il
va falloir les attendre il va falloir
passer une matinée là où ont passé deux
heures il va falloir assurer des formes
de 2,2 de roulement et un dispositif de
sécurité excessivement lourd qui dans
les faits conduira à ne plus
perquisitionné certains endroits et donc
à de collecter moins de preuve et donc à
assurer l'impunité d'un certain des gens
parce que encore une fois il faudra
donner des adresses
or on est dans des systèmes ou des fois
on va d'un endroit à l'autre extrêmement
rapidement parce que au cours d'une
première perquisition on trouve une
deuxième adresse
et puis et puis on y va et là donc il y
aura une lourdeur énorme et tout cela
c'est que il n'y a jamais eu de de
remise en cause de deux perquisitions au
motif qu'elle aurait lieu sans avocat c
une demande des avocats qui leur permet
pour les avocats commis d'office de
d'être plus présent et d'être rémunérés
sur un certain nombre de dates
supplémentaires au delà de ce fait des
auditions actuellement pratiqués dans
les commissariats si monsieur monsieur
la colère puis après ce sera monsieur
leroy puis monsieur richard houis jouer
juste apporter un dernier entraînement
c'est l'article 56 en matière de saisie
est scellée par rapport aux
perquisitions qui nous pose un souci
puisque en fait elles saisissent télé on
doit le faire en temps réel maintenant
lorsqu'il ya énormément de matériel à
saisir une exploitation qui est faite
aux services l article 56 prévoit lancer
les provisoires
en revanche pour les saisissez les ils
doivent être faits et signé par toutes
les parties qui ont assisté à la
perquisition ce qui veut dire que l'opgi
reste encore donc à la disposition de la
voiture le lendemain lorsque celui ci
sera disponible ce qui nous pose
également pas en gros ce aussi bien que
chez le roi merci monsieur le président
je voudrais juste importé 2 précisions
la première si sur le bobo de la
sécurité et la deuxième sur le rapport
sur l'état des forces de sécurité dont a
parlé le premier intervenant donc nous
avons dans le cas du beauvau de la
sécurité où siègent tous les syndicats
de police vous êtes tous se représenter
nous avons fait une table ronde de
exactement le 27 mai sur ce sujet police
justice en présence du garde des sceaux
et du ministère de l'intérieur durant
quatre heures et demie les élus ont eu
la parole 20 à 30 minutes
l'ensemble des syndicats pendant trois
heures à peu près et les ministres
pendant une demi heure à peu près donc
je voulais vous dire si vous ne le savez
déjà mais je suis convaincu que vos
représentants beauvau de la sécurité
vous en informer tout ce que vous venez
de préciser de nous détailler de nous
apporter ont été exprimées de façon très
claire très détaillé tantôt ministre de
la justice comme ministre de l'intérieur
donc on peut pas aujourd'hui dire que
les ministres n'ont pas été informés de
toutes vos préoccupations en ce qui
concerne si vous voulez l'ensemble que
ce soit les perquisitions que ce soit
les gardes à vue que ce soit tous vos
problèmes dans la procédure pénale
et je crois que ça a été bien entendu je
voudrais juste vous préciser que lors de
mon intervention quand j'ai compris que
le garde des sceaux me disait qu'il
avait entendu parler de nos travaux et
je viens à la deuxième précision puisque
le rapport sur l'état des forces de sico
était que nous avons établies et remis à
l'époque aux premiers ministres edouard
philippe et au ministre de l'intérieur
je crois que c'était collomb il me
semble ou son successeur
nous avons pendant six mois à 21
sénateurs us 4 480 une audition quarante
deux tables rondes 18 déplacement
terrain et cette séance qui s'est passé
s'est passé en présence et sous le
l'observation du procureur de la
république de clermont ferrand
donc nous avons retransmis la commission
des lois monsieur le président
l'administration des lois a retransmis
une nouvelle fois les 350 pages de ce
rapport sur l'état des forces de
sécurité qui était présidée par michel
bouton dont le rapporteur était françois
grosdidier
donc j'en ai discuté ensuite avec le
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il ne l'avait
jamais vu je pense que je ne pense pas
je crois qu'il n'a jamais vu puisque il
me l'a dit et le ministre de l'intérieur
l'a vraisemblablement dans ses tiroirs
mais je lui ai retransmis une deuxième
fois pour que tout ce que vous avez dit
durant ces six mois tout ce qu'on a pu
recueillir toutes les observations que
vous avez formulées aujourd'hui ont bien
été porté dans le cas du bureau de la
sécurité qui a été instituée justement
par le président de la république alors
je pense que le gouvernement ne peut pas
ignorer aujourd'hui tout ce que vous
revendiquez dans tous les domaines on
vous souffre énormément et pour le sénat
ou non du sénat puisque j'ai fait et
vous retrouverez les quatre propositions
qui correspond un petit peu à ces
conclusions du rapport de la sécurité de
l'état des forces de sécurité qui ont
été actualisés sur le terrain 1 le
cursus de la formation initiale en stage
d'immersion d'un côté comme de l'autre
entre les policiers et les magistrats
qui a été entérinée en tout cas par le
procureur de la république de clermont
ferrand qui représentait la magistrature
la réforme totale du code de procédure
pénale puisque en trente ans je crois
que le volume du code de procédure
pénale a été multiplié par 8 et où si je
cite si je cite le co-rapporteur jacques
bobe de la simplification de la
procédure pénale et je le cite
intégralement la lourdeur de la
procédure pénale est incontestable le
code de procédure pénale est illisible
temps pour nos enquêteurs que pour le
parquet le juge d'instruction et la
quasi totalité des intervenants des
intervenants delà de la procédure pénale
puis nous avons parlé aussi de
localisation et de la dématérialisation
voilà les quatre procédures que les
quatre propositions que vous retrouvez
d'ailleurs dans le rapport sur l'état
des forces de sécurité voilà ce que je
voulais préciser monsieur le président
si l'on reçoit la dématérialisation je
peux vous informer que de 10 youn rond
je dis madame de montchanin et monsieur
dupont moretti sur l'aspect judiciaire
pendant l occasion leur poser la
question sur les policiers messieurs
richard mais président je voudrais vous
faire une petite indication de méthode
que je répète de temps en temps parce
que je trouve vraiment c'est que c'est
très insatisfaisant je suis frappé de la
pauvreté ou de l'inexistence des
statistiques portant sur le fond des
jugements et on sait très peu de choses
sur ce qui est finalement jugée en
france
c'est vrai au pénal c'est vrai dans les
autres champs de la l'activité
judiciaire et je pense qu'il faut
rappeler ça au garde des sceaux
successifs parce que c'est aussi un
outil de travail pour naturellement
police nature mais aussi pour
l'administration de la justice
la remarque devrait faire c'est que
ici comme législateur nous sommes en
priorité concerné par l'évolution du
code de procédure pénale et
alourdissement est facteur de paralysie
qu'il englobe et le déséquilibre entre
les parties qu'il enregistre aujourd'hui
et donc de mon point de vue c'est ça la
priorité et du fait que dans son
organisation
et bien sûr on peut aussi adresser la
même suggestion aux gendarmes il y a
beaucoup de spécialistes de d'acteurs de
terrain de la procédure pénale
je crois que nous aurions besoin d'un
relevé extrêmement factuel écrit
détaillée des dispositions du code de
procédure pénale qui sont les plus soit
paralysante soit génératrice de risques
d'erreur et avocat pénaliste
c'est d'abord un métier de procédurier
donc je pense que c'est particulièrement
productif de vérifier ce qu'il ya dans
le tableau de chasse des avocats
pénalistes c'est à dire les procédures
qu'ils arrivent à faire tomber en
utilisant des modèles disposition du cpp
il me semble que c'est vraiment à partir
de ça qu'il faut que nous travaillons il
se trouve que je représente cette maison
au conseil supérieur de codification à
la commission par un supérieur de
codification où nous revoyons
régulièrement mettons en ordre les
différents textes et ses glands retirer
les incohérences et que les collègues et
les personnes plus qualifiées combat
juridiquement qui y siègent sont
convaincus que le cpp présente dans les
faits des travers important en tant que
texte
donc il me semble qu'il ya matière à un
dialogue très professionnelle très
factuelle sur les points critiques du
cpp et ce qui est remédiable sans porter
atteinte au caractère élémentaires des
droits de la défense de la liberté
disons 2
de ne pas s'exprimer de la part du
prévenu que nous rappelle à juste titre
au vu de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme le conseil constitutionnel mais
qu'on peu aménagée de façon moins
problématique et je voudrais ajouter une
question c'est au fond puisque nous
observons du fait de ses difficultés
une désinfection un moindre attrait pour
les postes de procédure de police
judiciaire du coup pour le personnel
qualifié qui aurait le potentiel y
aurait au départ un intérêt pour la
procédure judiciaire pour la paix la
police judiciaire qu'est-ce qu'ils
prennent en 2d comme ans comment est-ce
que se traduit ce déséquilibre est cette
perte d'attractivité
merci monsieur richard peut-être
certains troubles sexuels et monsieur
vous en prie monsieur oui je vous
remercie monsieur le président et puis
pour pour répondre peut-être déjà à la
remarque de monsieur leroy sur le
rapport de 2018 qui a été effectivement
un travail conséquent je crois qu'on a
un problème aussi c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur c'est le ministère de
l'urgence monsieur darmanin et je crois
le neuvième ministre de l'intérieur en
dix ans le troisième de ce quinquennat
à chaque fois qu'il ya un changement de
ministre un changement d'équipé on se
retrouve à ré expliquer nos
problématiques qui ne sont pourtant pas
nouvelle les constats effectivement ont
été posées notamment au moment du bo de
la sécurité mais nous les posons nous
représentants du personnel depuis un
moment assez long et c'est vrai que à
chaque fois pour tout ce qui est réforme
d'ampleur
on se heurte ensuite à un calendrier
qu'ils soient politiques médiatiques etc
qui n'est pas toujours le même que celui
des des attentes des personnels
concernant le code de procédure pénale
je vais reprendre les mots de mon
secrétaire général justement la table
ronde du beauvau sur la justice il a dit
qu'il s'agissait maintenant d'un monstre
qui était devenu inintelligible même
pour les professionnels c'est vrai que
dans ce cpp actuellement il ya un petit
côté frankenstein parce qu'à chaque loi
de procédure pénale il y en a quand même
assez souvent on le modifie donc en plus
il ya un manque de stabilité au delà
même de ce qu'on en pense sur le fond
les enquêteurs les magistrats consacre
une bonne partie de leur temps à
comprendre à chaque texte
ce qui va changer pour eux dans le
quotidien à la suite des dispositions
qui sont adoptés
on peut évidemment faire remonter des
dysfonctionnements de manière
extrêmement précise et dire ce qui est
bloquant au quotidien mais tout
simplement il faudrait envisager de le
réécrire alors c'est un chantier qui ne
peut pas se mener en 15 jours et qu'il
doit aux sans préjudice du rôle
évidemment du parlement à l'issue du
processus associés les enquêteurs qu'ils
soient policiers et gendarmes mais aussi
les magistrats mais aussi avocats
notre procédure pénale aujourd'hui elle
est au milieu du gué
on n'a pas choisi entre l'inquisitoire
l'accusatoire est-ce qu'on est sur un
modèle anglo saxon est ce qu on veut
rester sur le modèle français
traditionnel est ce que nous disent nos
collègues c'est que finalement pour les
enquêteurs
on cumule les difficultés des deux
modèles et au bout d'un moment il va
falloir choisir il va falloir peut-être
pas c'est effectivement un travail de
réécriture de ce code qui est qui est
important en remettant à plat l'ensemble
l'ensemble des dispositions avec les
professionnels on est bien conscient que
le vul vu le calendrier ça n'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui va pouvoir
être lancées dans l'immédiat mais voilà
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
important et par rapport aux états
généraux de la justice je pense que ce
sera aussi un des enjeux nous on attend
de savoir comment on va être associés ou
pas en tant que co organisation
représentative
les fonctionnaires de police parce que
ça a été plus ou moins 10 qui aura une
association des citoyens et des
représentants des enquêteurs
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
toujours positif qu'on débatte mais je
crois que les problèmes de la justice
on ne va pas les découvrir non plus à
l'occasion des états généraux de la
justice et notamment les problèmes de
moyens ils sont exprimées par les
représentants respectifs des magistrats
les agents d'insertion et probation et
c'est donc une nouvelle fois on va se
réunir on va on va débattre mais il ne
faudrait pas que comme ça a été exprimée
tout à l'heure nos collègues constatent
que concrètement pendant qu'on fait
d'eux qu'on organise de nouveau débat et
de nouveaux rendez-vous à une fois de
plus la procédure pénale s'alourdit et
pour pour répondre sur les services qui
sont choisis ensuite on va dire il peut
y avoir un mouvement un petit peu
inverse à celui qu'on connaissait il ya
un certain nombre d'années où le
mouvement logique on va dire quand on
arrivait dans la police
c'était de commencer par la voie
publique
et puis ensuite de rejoindre un service
d'investigation au niveau d'un
commissariat puis peut-être un service
services spécialisés aujourd'hui il ya
évidemment une diversité de l'aspiration
de nos collègues à la fois sur le plan
géographique et sur le plan de
spécialisation mais beaucoup de beaucoup
de collègues et notamment fatigué de
l'investigation de ces risques d'erreurs
de ses de cette tension quotidienne vont
se diriger plutôt effectivement vers
vers des services soin de vos publics
pour certains sur des services de
renseignement qui préserve un aspect
d'investigation mais s'en est souvenu au
formalisme procédural même s'il a
évidemment des règles qui encadrent les
les procédures administratives dans
lesquelles il est dans le cadre
desquelles ils travaillent donc voilà ce
qu'ont ce qu'on observe c'est
effectivement ça a été dit par pascal
thaler que notamment dans les
commissariats à préfecture de police
vous allez aujourd'hui dans un
commissariat de seine saint denis vous
avez toutes les chances de retrouver au
sein du service d'accueil et
d'investigation de proximité des
gardiens de la paix sortie d'école qui
seront encadrés par un lieutenant sortie
d'école avec au-dessus potentiellement
un commissaire sortie d'école parce que
vous avez des territoires et des
fonctions effectivement les fonctions
d'investigation qui sont devenus
extrêmement peu attractive et tout le
tout ce qu'on est en train de dire sur
le code de procédure pénale c'est
évidemment important parce que si les
mesures indemnitaire j'en ai parlé tout
à l'heure
elles ont tout leur sens elles ont tous
leur rôle pour reconnaître ces les
officiers de police judiciaire quelles
que soient leurs corps et pour
reconnaître le travail judiciaire qui
est fait passer avant tout redonner du
sens aussi au travail de nos collègues
qui pourra les attirer à nouveau vers
l'investigation c'est qu'ils aient
l'impression de pouvoir faire de l'
enquête et non pas de mots retire des
procès verbaux uniquement pour respecter
les obligations procédurales dont ils
comprennent de moins en moins le sens
caché sa colère
merci pour vous répondre pourquoi j'ai
travaillé 20 ans police judiciaire donc
j'ai un peu d'expérience et je les
quitte est justement pour les
renseignements généraux pourquoi parce
que justement il ya plus ce formalisme
et judiciaire qui est devenu trop lourd
aujourd'hui un enquêteur c'est plus en
inquiète heures on travaille plus du
tout sur le fond on travaille que sur le
formalisme
en fait on est devenu des techniciens il
faut est habilité pour tous il n'y a
plus aucun intérêt dans le métier donc
c'est une des problématiques c'est pas
qu'une question d'argent l'argent moi je
le dis clairement ce même pour 200 ou
300 euros j'y retournerai pas ça ne
m'intéresse pas mon intérêt mais au
quotidien c'est mon métier et ont
franchement on n'y trouve plus plaisir
pas d'autres interventions à un bras à
s'élever à lecce il voulait rajouter une
chose par rapport aux interrogations
sauf si j'ai mal compris de monsieur le
sénateur richard sur la finalité
l'interrogation sur la finalité des
peines je rappelle tout simplement que
nous avons eu les mêmes interrogations
puisque nous avions proposé à certaines
époques et réaffirmé lors de cette
manifestation
la mise en place d'un observatoire de la
réponse pénale contre ceux qui agressent
les forces de l'ordre en tout cas ces
pannes pour nous faire plaisir c'est
simplement pour démontrer que en
finalité de la chaîne pénale c'est à
dire la décision du magistrat
pourquoi aujourd'hui l'autorité remis en
cause alors certes celle du policier
mais en finalité celle du citoyen parce
que quand on agresse aujourd'hui
impunément un policier en tout cas les
forces de l'ordre on peut imaginer
comment on peut s'en prendre
par ailleurs un élu comment on peut s'en
prendre par ailleurs à un prof est
encore plus facilement un citoyen donc
tout ça est une chaîne qui nécessitent
des prises de décisions nous l'avons dit
et si l'une des raisons pourquoi nous
avons fait cette revendication enfin
nous avons voulu cette revendication les
uns et les autres c'est à dire cet
observatoire pour partir sur le principe
de la peine encourue
lorsqu on agresse un policier bon il ya
une peine encourue c'est le code pénal
ensuite il ya la peine prononcée par le
juge mais ensuite il ya ce qui se passe
dans les salons dorés
c'est à dire la peine qui est réellement
effectués et ça c'est lorsque l'individu
à la chance ou la malchance j'en sais
rien de passer devant le jld
et c'est là où on en revient à ce qui
avait été dit tout à l'heure c'est le
principe de l'aménagement de peine qui
aujourd'hui est devenu la règle contre
la prison qui est aussi qui est
l'exception
donc voilà
si le pourquoi du comment nous sommes
dans l'obligation ce qui est dramatique
d'exercer un contrôle parce que c'est
une sorte de contrôle sur les magistrats
pour en tout cas en arriver à ce que
nous avons dit c'est qu'aujourd'hui peu
d'individus sont sanctionnés hormis bien
sûr les affaires médiatiques contre ceux
qui agressent les policiers et une somme
sur un principe idéologique qui fait que
aujourd'hui les magistrats
alors j'ai horreur de généraliser on va
dire en tout cas une partie de la
magistrature
ah non là on peut dire la justice même
on peut on peut généraliser sur le
principe idéologique bon sanctionne
aujourd'hui davantage temps de
sanctionner davantage ceux qui ont 20 25
50 fait derrière eux plutôt que de
sanctionner ceux qui commettent leur
première infraction
donc ça c'est le choix on va dire da
philosophie ou la doctrine de politique
pénale à la française qui n'est pas le
choix d'ailleurs de certains autres pays
je rappelle démocratiques qui ont fait
le choix de de sanctionner dès la
première infraction
alors là aussi une interrogation avoir
sur le principe des états généraux de la
justice qui fait qu'à un moment donné
c'est un peu le serpent qui se mord la
queue si on n'a pas de places de prison
bien évidemment on pourra pas mettre en
prison
et dire que la la prison et l'école du
crime
elle restera à l'école du crime dès lors
où ceux qui vont sont déjà formés au
crime bon donc un moment donné faut
savoir ce qu'on veut et si on
s'interroge sur la récidive par rapport
à des gens qui ont 25 50 cent fait je
vous assure que je suis persuadé que
certains d'entre vous ne passez pas
c'est que ces questions tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est que non ça passe pas
du tout donc voilà aussi pourquoi je
voulais intervenir derrière la question
alors si ce n'est peut-être pas celle là
c'est celle que je souhaite répondre sur
l'observatoire de la réponse pénale est
pourquoi nous en sommes arrivés là pour
démontrer aujourd'hui que
malheureusement la justice sanctionne
peu ceux qui s'attaquent injustement aux
policiers enfin vendu par les forces de
l'anp et merci est ce que on peut
considérer je pose une question que
votre préoccupation première vous avez
relevé trois points principaux la
philosophie générale la sanction pénale
l'exécution de la peine est ce que l'on
peut considérer aujourd'hui que c'est
moins le quantum de la peine prononcée
je prends je suis prudent parce que sur
celle d'un certain nombre de personnes
faisant autorité
on comprend l'aggravation de celle ci
que l'importance absolue de l'exécution
rapide de la peine
oui oui si vous permettez un saut
sénateurs et bien en fait j'ai envie de
dire les deux le quantum de la peine et
je rappelle que le document qu'elle je
faisais référence tout à l'air qui est
un document officiel qui vient de la
chancellerie qui a été transmis et
annexé dans un rapport du sénat fait
état d' avoir des taux d'emprisonnement
prononcée et les quantum de peine par
rapport aux peines encourues et camp
d'ouvriers de décalage par exemple pour
des attaques envers une personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
avec sans itt était donc ça veut dire
sans une circonstance qui ferait passer
à par exemple à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement dont on est sûr des
peines encourues deux trois ans eh bien
le quantum moyen est de 5,8 mois quand
vous savez que la grille des peines
depuis 2019 et bien oblige pour toute
peine inférieure à 6 mois de
l'aménagement de peine du coup le
raccourci est fait pour une agression
envers un policier
c'est un aménagement de peine et il n'y
a pas la case prison et ça c'est vrai
que sur la symbolique par rapport au
respect de l'autorité de l'état par
rapport à la protection des dépositaires
de l'autorité publique
et bien c'est un mauvais signal et c'est
un signal qui encouragent et qui
entretient cette impunité qui s'est
inséré dans la société d'aujourd'hui
donc ça c'est cesser et je dirais que le
quantum de la peine et l'exécution de la
peine
sondés
élément indissociable de même lorsque
vous avez des peines prononcées et qui
vont au delà je dirais par exception des
peines supérieures à un an
vous savez très bien qu'au bout d'un
certain temps avec la réduction des
peines automatiques avec la réduction
des peines pour bon comportement
eh bien vous avez des aménagements qui
sont prononcés en cours d'exécution des
peines
et ce qui fait que là encore on nous
explique que c'est de leur réinsertion
mais alors la question que j'ai envie de
poser c'est ces personnes lorsqu'ils
rentrent par la case prison qu'il n'y
rentre pas le taux de récidive
là aussi nous manquons de statistiques
nous avons regardé les chiffres de la
justice je suis incapable de vous dire
aujourd'hui que un primo délinquant qui
rentrera en prison devient récidivistes
parce que ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui ce sont des récidivistes
simplement qu'ils vont en prison
c'est comme ça que en fait le système il
s'est instauré
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont fait à gestion
de la population carcérale
alors que l'on devrait raisonner en
terme de gravité d'infraction de
préjudice si oui et surtout ne
l'oublions pas dans ce débat il ya un
peu les victimes dont il faut s'occuper
aussi bien sûr alors monsieur
bonnecarrère je crois la parole oui
merci monsieur le président vous m'avez
confiées avec mes collègues de la
commission le rapport sur le test
confiance dans les institutions
judiciaires dont on a parlé à plusieurs
reprises
je vais donc me concentrer sur ce
rapport à d y en a forcément une
approche plus technique et en m'excusant
de ne pas me placer sous laon de la
crise de l'autorité du stress des
policiers de la violence de la société
des nombreux éléments qui ont été
évoquées par les uns et les autres
qu'elle je suis particulièrement
sensible mais
là on technique législatif est bien
obligé de revenir aux dispositions elle
même j'aurai quatre questions à poser
que je vous présente globalement ce qui
me permettra de les individualiser si
notre président année d'accord c'est
pour vous voyez le cadre général
j'aurais une première question sur la
chronologie
vous êtes invités à deux vous serez
invités probablement à des états
généraux de la justice quelque part avec
l'automne et le mois d'octobre est ce
que ce calendrier est compatible avec
l'adoption de la leur confiance dans les
instituts dans les institutions
judiciaires à fin septembre si on suit
le calendrier actuel mais deuxième et
troisième question pose reporteront sur
le contenu lui même du texte en vous
proposant assez banalement de regarder
ce qu'il ya dans le texte et de regarder
ce qu'il n'ya pas et de faire ensuite un
focus bien sûr sur la question de la
procédure pénale qui a été largement
présent dans votre propre donc si
président accepte je commencerai par une
première question de calendrier
qu'est ce que vous pensez des états
généraux de la justice à l'automne avec
un texte qui a priori est dans votre
coeur de cible et qui aurait été adoptée
quelques jours avant en d'autres termes
elle et vous portez vis-à-vis de la
chancellerie du ministère l'industrie ce
l'idée tout simplement qui serait
raisonnable
dawn examiner ce texte confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire qu'après les
états dg denis drolet justice y compris
pour permettre d'intégrer les résultats
des dix états généraux votre avis sur
lequel on my bien qu'ils se jettent l
eau monsieur je rejoins votre
questionnement le calendrier pose
question effectivement il ya un petit
souci une aversion au delà de ça je
reviendrais et moi bien avant ça je
reviendrais sur le bobo de la sécurité
pourquoi se tient t-il alors qu'on avait
toute la matière pour statuer sur la
question de sécurité grâce au livre
blanc sur la sécurité intérieure
je pense que ça se vaut la sécurité
lorsqu'il a été annoncé à l'estomac qui
est pas mal de monde se bouge la
sécurité on espère qu'il en émergera
quand quelque chose de consistant
mais ceci retarde aussi l'élaboration
d'une loppsi qui est appelée de nos
voeux une loi d'orientation de
programmation la sécurité intérieure
aujourd'hui il faut arrêter avec le
temps court les effets d'annoncé on veut
nous qu'on donne du sens à notre
profession on veut de la perspective on
va arrêter de naviguer à vue
et pourquoi un beau la sécurité pourquoi
pas plutôt en matignon de la sécurité
aujourd'hui quand vous avez une fuite
chez vous vous mettez pas des
serpillières vous appelez le plombier
aujourd'hui on a une délinquance
galopante
on peut construire des places de prison
comme ça si si on n'agit pas sur les
causes entend construire advitam eternam
mais s'ils ont un gamin commence déjà à
soult et est frappé ses parents insulté
et frappé
l'instituteur l'institutrice comment
voulez vous qu'ils ne frappent pas le
policier lorsqu'il à 14 15 16 17 18 ans
aujourd'hui ce sont les pompiers qui
traquent nouveau phénomène
ça va en empirant donc on appelle nous à
la cvt de nos voeux à un projet un
projet social sociétal de lutte contre
la délinquance
mêlant tous les acteurs de notre société
institutionnels associatifs
donc il s'agit il s'agirait de mettre
autour de la table les personnels de la
petite enfance de soutien à la
parentalité l'éducation nationale bien
entendu la justice la police les
les acteurs de l'insertion
professionnelle notamment les uns les
acteurs de la politique de la ville donc
aujourd'hui
agissons sur les causes arrêtons de de
traiter les symptômes
peut-être juste en complément c'est
aussi sur cette question des mineurs
délinquants que la célérité et la
certitude de la sanction est importante
parce que justement avant qu'ils
s'engagent dans un parcours de
délinquance quelqu'un qui commet un
premier effet à 15 ou 16 ans ça n'aura
pas beaucoup de sens de le juger et de
lui infliger une peine deux ans après si
entre temps il a déjà activé et c'est
donc là dessus il ya effectivement un
sujet de rapidité sans me l'ensemble des
autres sujets qu'on a balayé mais
évidemment police et justice c'est vrai
on intervient à la fin de d'une chaîne
quand il ya déjà des problèmes donc on
ne peut pas non plus tout régler à nous
mêmes
je rappelle aux collègues la dernière
loppsi aide 2002 et qu'elle a été
reprise en 2011
il ya vingt ans et 10 ans on peut
imaginer que notre programmation qui
interviendrait dans un peu de
perspective est un peu de certitudes ce
qu'on a fait pour la justice quand le
texte de 2018 je re alors attendait une
réponse et allez-y monsieur soit vous
levez la main asie oui oui on le faisait
on partage pas du tout l'avis d'un deux
intervenants précédents le blanc uni a
participé on était dans ce marais des
groupes de travail au public
il est la somme des montants d'assurance
il a on a été un instrument avoir
longtemps elle était entendue le livre
relance
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à
l'occasion de leur aurait de la
sexualité est particulièrement
l'occasion de l'atelier portant sur eure
alors la soupe les justices à les
syndicats sont très entendu en tout cas
leur faculté à s'exprimer alors c'est
pas engageant sur ce qu'on en retiendra
mémoire on a un sentiment d'avoir pu
dire tout ce qu'ils avaient à dire
et croyez-nous pour les policiers c'est
déjà beaucoup
et puis il
il faisait un plan large de
l'institution police nationale de la
sécurité intérieure plus entière
d'ailleurs le beaucoup d'instituts avait
t il et puis ça perd la poche
macroscopique des choses et notamment un
esthète des personnels vous nous
demandiez s'il n'y avait pas un problème
de calendrier
si on était tellement convaincu encore
une fois parce que des sceaux occasion
de dire ce que l'on pense de dire notre
sentiment sur la situation devenait
vedette quelques solutions assez
pragmatique qui nous viennent on en a
tellement l'avait évoqué tout à l'heure
les commissions de travail
ono nathalie qu on ya participé à
plusieurs reprises et on avait des
interlocuteurs qui semblait complètement
partager tous les constats que nous
faisions qui semblait adhérer aux
solutions que nous arrivions et puis
comme à plein d'autres occasions
au bout du bout pour les policiers il se
passe rien ou bien encore très souvent
on en pliant n'aggrave la situation
donc oui on pourrait imaginer si on
répondait vraiment quelque chose puis
ceux définitivement améliorer la
condition des policiers leur quotidien
leurs activités notamment dans les
services d'investigation
on pourrait penser qu'il ya maladresse
dans lequel ont veillé mais ont tenu de
ce qu'il en sortira en bout finalement
d'un sentiment que ce concours de
circonstances
après tellement malheureux monsieur
bonne carrière deuxième question portant
sur ce qu'il y a dans le texte dit de
confiance alors je ne reviens pas sur la
question des perquisitions je comprends
que vous êtes déjà exprimé là-dessus
mais je voudrais un petit peu plus votre
sentiment sur la question des enquêtes
préliminaires qui serait limité
à deux ans ce qui est une autre manière
un petit peu d'endroits fil des
observations du président du fai aidant
à richard de vous demandez pas des
éléments statistiques mais finalement
les enquêtes préliminaires qui dure plus
de deux ans est-ce qu'il y en a beaucoup
dans quel domaine
est ce que nous sommes en train de
parler uniquement du trafic de drogue
est ce qu'on est en train de parler
uniquement du travail du parquet
national financier qu'est ce qui lie à
derrière pour vous cette question blé
dur et des procédures préliminaires et
je considère que vous avez répondu sur
les réductions de peine
j'aurais aimé que vous me disiez un mot
du rappel à la loi
je crois que vos organismes ne sont pas
des enthousiastes du rappel
à la loi qui serait subitement supprimés
mais la première des choses à laquelle
on pense quand on supprime quelque chose
c'est à ce moment là
par quoi on le remplace et finalement
comment se fait la conciliation entre
des choses que vous connaissez par coeur
le fait que la société effect 2 que le
nombre de places de prison est limité et
caetera et en même temps d'assurer une
forme d'effectivité de la sanction donc
qu'est-ce que vous mettriez à la place
du rappel à la loi
si effectivement vous manifestiez votre
accord sur sa sur ces suppressions
enquête préliminaire
rappel à la loi ce qui serait possible
d'avoir votre réaction
sur ces deux éléments qui sont dans le
texte merci les gars messieurs 1
rappelez moi votre nom parce que j'ai et
monsieur asie ne suive partir un vol à
travers aller des préliminaires alors
attentivement c'est pareil pour avoir
été très sollicité dans le cadre de la
commission m et la demande est très
dense il garde des souvenirs et non déjà
commis magistrats que les premiers
policiers
nous avions donné nous traîne par
rapport à la technique fication combien
de gars comme vient de le dire mon
collègue fonds n'était et égouttez les
partants des puisque effectivement les
dispositions les plus contraignantes en
effet reconnu on va intégrer dans le
projet de loi c'est une première chose
déjà aujourd'hui à 1061 les suivantes et
peu très peu de très bonnes dispositions
du texte actuel peut être suivie de par
l'anah ce dossier je vais vous parler
d'un contentieux financier il ya des
dossiers qui seront pas celui ci me fait
un peu de texte avec les délais qui sont
bonnes elles sont suivies par woods
s'est très vite
deux ans avec une pétition de trois
conditions soient négociées
ça peut être très très petit mec pour
mes collègues entraîneurs c'est la
charge mentale qui va peser sur eux par
ses romans au moins entre lorsqu'ils
sont déjà submergés de dossier lorsque
doit plus y voir la lumière
et lorsqu'une tête le regard des
indications certainement du parti les
dossiers en quoi il va y avoir une
charge mentale infernale sur certaines
ne sort certaines infractions et
collègues ne seront que dans la course
la course à l'échalote se dirige ensuite
mes dossiers festif et le fond du
dossier dentaire perdre tout son sens si
ce bien la gestion de calendrier
contraint par ce nouveau texte
voilà ce qui m'inquiète sur sur cette
enquête préliminaire quand on sait
qu'aujourd'hui des armoires entières
dans les commissariats de france sont
plein de dossiers de 2016 2015 n'ayant
pu être traitées ou en attente de
réquisition me voilà pourquoi redevenir
plus d'enseignants si ce n'est pour en
servir certaines certaines infractions
actuelles ou à venir prévue par ce texte
oui sur sur cette question des enquêtes
préliminaires alors je l'avais rappelé
tout à l'heure nous on a des
interrogations effectivement sur ce que
vont devenir les procédures qui n'auront
pas pu être orientés par un magistral
dans la durée de deux ans ça concerne
effectivement un certain nombre de
procédures y compris en commissariat et
on l'avait déjà dit au moment de la
commission mattei ce qui nous inquiète
un petit peu dans cette philosophie
c'est qu'on a l'impression suffirait de
d'imposer par la loi une durée limite
pour que finalement les policiers et les
magistrats qui se tournaient un petit
peu les pouces décide fils de traiter
leurs dossiers plus rapidement et de les
finir dans les délais qu'on leur impose
désormais vous aurez bien compris à
l'exposé de nos difficultés qu'il ne
s'agit pas de ça que nos collègues dans
les services d'investigation sont
débordés donc concrètement quand vous
avez 200 300 parfois plus dossier en
portefeuille va déjà falloir faire un
recensement
pendant ce temps là vous aurez d'autres
procédures qui vont continuer à arriver
quid effectivement du collet qui sera
muté qui ne sera pas remplacé donc
peut-être que ces dossiers seront
effectivement réattribué à quelqu'un
d'autre mais concrètement qui va
reprendre
procédure pour aller l'a présenté à un
magistrat avant les deux ans on a
l'impression que les dispositions du
projet de loi d'une manière générale
sont pensés pour quelques dossiers de
grande délinquance financière notamment
extérieur sauf que derrière le code de
procédure pénale s'appliquant y compris
aux affaires concrètes dans les
commissariats et aux contentieux de
masse
ça risque d'avoir des conséquences assez
assez importante et assez préjudiciable
parce qu'aujourd'hui si nos collègues ne
traite pas rapidement les enquêtes
préliminaires c'est évidemment pas parce
qu'on n'en n'ont pas envie on parlait de
charge mentale c'est une réalité parce
que derrière il ya aussi des victimes
qui appelle qui nous disent où en est
mon dossier
sauf que quand on appelle les magistrats
et nous disent vous avoue prioriser vous
faites le très très urgent qui va passer
avant le 13 heures jean et avant
l'urgence est derrière le dossier qui ne
l'est pas il ya aussi il ya aussi une
victime qui attend donc on fait en
fonction des moyens humains et matériels
qui sont les nôtres et ça
malheureusement il suffit pas de changer
la loi pour pouvoir faire évoluer la
situation d'un coup de baguette magique
là dessus concernant le rappel à la loi
on a effectivement une interrogation on
est on accueille assez favorablement sa
suppression
c'est une modalité de classement sans
suite donc nos collègues sont plutôt
contents de devoir qui va disparaître en
tant que tel par contre je crois qu'il
ya à peu près autour de 300 milles
rappel à la loi prononcé par an
j'ai quelques doutes sur la capacité de
l'institution judiciaire est la nôtre à
faire concrètement appliquée une 3008
amende ou 3000 m de 3000 travaux
d'intérêts généraux par an 300 milles
donc voilà je c'est une vraie question y
compris certains magistrats
nous nous disent qu'ils n'auront pas
d'autre choix que de presser pour
d'autres motifs finalement parce que le
rappel à la loi était utilisée dans des
procédures aussi ou ou éclats c'est
parce qu'ils estimaient que les faits
étaient d'une importance relativement
faible si c'est ça on ne sera pas
satisfait naturellement à l'issue 6-7
6-7 suppression n'aboutit pas à des
sanctions effectives dans les dossiers
concernant ce jeu c'est peut-être une
des bandes adhésives monsieur oui nous
venons pour alliance
juste pour rappeler une chose quand même
le rappel à la loi est une alternative
aux poursuites et qui fait partie
d'ailleurs dans les classements sans
suite pour les affaires non conçu peuple
je rappelle aussi que si c'est pour
remplacer le rappel à la loi par une
autre alternative aux poursuites et ne
pas se poser la question de la gravité
des faits et de la peine encourue et on
n'aura pas répondu à la question si vous
faites du rappel à la loi pour une
agression envers un policier
le décalage entre la peine encourue la
peine prononcée il est énorme et si vous
le remplacer par des travaux d'intérêts
généraux des jours amendes
vous n'aurez pas répondu à la je dirais
la politique pénale de fermeté que les
policiers attendent donc attention à ne
pas remplacer l'un par un autre et qui
est la même couleur et la même saveur
parce que quelqu'un on n'aura pas
répondu à la table des policiers merci
monsieur c'est votre carrière troisième
question ce qu'il n'y a pas dans le
texte confiance est ce que vous pourriez
nous donner vu par définition du point
de vue des policiers
si je fais exprimer les choses autrement
dans un exercice où interviennent les
services de police et gendarmerie mais
aussi la justice et la défense
pour la partie et qui vous concerne donc
police qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé
trouver dans ce texte qu est-ce qu
ignorer
qu'est-ce qui aurait du sens pour pour
vous et que vous n'avez pas trouvé
qu'elle serait l'élément je vais prendre
un exemple le
vous avez bien sûr évoqué les agressions
ou les drames dont peuvent être victimes
les policiers
le garde des sceaux va vous dire mais
nous avons allongé la durée de la
période de sûreté pour les meurtres à
l'égard des policiers
je comprends très bien cet objectif
j'avoue que je serai j'aurais peut-être
plus attendu des mesures
comment dire plus tendant à faciliter
les enquêtes je pense en particulier à
tout les a toutes les procédures que
vous pouvez mener dans les infractions
dites en bande organisée ou vous pouvez
utiliser toute une série de techniques
d'investigation qui ne sont pas possible
autrement j'aurais plutôt attendu des
évolutions là dessus donc votre votre
sentiment sur ce qui aurait pu figurer
que vous n'y trouvez pas et vos idées à
cet égard je collecte où il m'a en fait
nous le véritable souci concerne en fait
l'investigation le contentieux de masse
donc et en fait on n'a pas d'élément de
réponse le le soucis que rencontre
l'officier de police judiciaire c'est
qu'il n'a pas l'opportunité des
poursuites
on a tous judiciariser mais en fait nous
procédures ont explosé ce que nous
souhaiterions c'est qu'en fait on est un
référent du parquet qu'ils soient
présents dans les services
d'investigation et qu'ils puissent faire
le tri en amont c'est ça nous permettra
de gagner un temps assez important par
rapport aux procédures puisqu'il ya
l'infraction d'ailleurs c'est le
problème que rencontrent nos collègues
c'est que le code de procédure code
pénal leur demande de constater les
infractions et de présenter à l'opg et
l'autre côté la politique pénale prévoit
de pas réprimer ou d'apporter une
réponse pénale qui ne suffit pas donc
nous conte ses tresses et en fait que le
tri soit fait en amont et pas après pas
une fois que le travail a été fait ce
qui permettrait donc des purs et déjà un
grand nombre de procédures qui ne sont
déjà pas traitées ou alors c'est ça de
les prioriser et en fait donc deux de
déplacer donc de l'enquète vers l'eau pj
compétent en fonction du degré de
l'infraction
merci mais peut-être d'une manière
générale simplifiée aussi tant pour les
magistrats d'ailleurs que pour les
enquêteurs
tous les comptes rendus obligatoires les
demandes oubliée d'autorisation de
réquisition notamment enquête
préliminaire c'est vrai qu'on a
énormément de deux temps qu'ils aient
perdu aussi parce que on est obligé de
faire des comptes rendus qui finalement
sont formels qui ne portent pas
nécessairement sur le fond du dossier et
je rentre pas dans tout ce qu'il
faudrait simplifier dans l'idéal quand
on réécrira le code de procédure pénale
mais dans l'immédiat ça aurait pu être
quelque chose qui figurera qui auraient
pu figurer dans le texte
merci sylvain carrère s'il n'y a pas
d'autres réactions la question proche
termine avec le focus sur le volet
procédure pénale qui est bien sûr le on
l'a bien senti au fur et à mesure de vos
interventions le le coeur du réacteur le
coeur de ce qui pose problème et vous
avez d'ailleurs beaucoup insisté sur le
fait que au sein du malaise de la police
française
le malaise se concentrer beaucoup sur la
police judiciaire août - c'était là où
vous estimiez qu'il y avait les défauts
de fonctionnement
donc sur ce que
notre collègue anne harris faire appeler
le tableau de chasse sur ce qui pourrait
être fait en matière de simplification
de la procédure pénale
vous paraîtrez t-il outrancier au risque
de se répéter de vous demander malgré
tout ce tableau de chasse et de vos noms
d ensemble des syndicats présents autour
de cette table ou par j par par visio de
nous communiquer votre corbeille votre
stock votre votre caisse je ne sais pas
quoi simplement aux propositions vos
propositions de modification des
dispositions de procédure pénale en
essayant là où je vais devenir peut-être
un peu compliqué où un petit peu
exigeant de deux ans vous de vous
pousser un petit peu dans vos
retranchements en nous communiquant ses
propositions pour nous permettre
collectivement nous n'avons pas le
monopole même si effectivement ni
forcément attaché de mesurer ce qui
relève du domaine législatif du domaine
réglementaire
parce que pour vous dire franchement les
choses quand j'ai nous ne vivons pas des
sénateurs ville ancrée dans l'est dans
les territoires nos histoires politiques
professionnels etc
le font aussi et quand nous discutons
sur le territoire gc10 sujet a pas très
longtemps avec man ddsp ce qu'il me
remonte dans les problèmes de procédure
pénale se sont systématiquement des
choses qui me paraissent être de nature
réglementaire du style pour notifier les
droits à l'étranger ce serait quand même
plus simple plutôt que de chercher
partout un traducteur de pouvoir
afficher sur l'écran de l'ordinateur
dentelle dentelle langue extraordinaire
les éléments qu pour que la personne de
voix sans être obligé de réquisitionner
ou d'attendre un producteur quand on
m'explique que pour les écoute il faut
retranscrire tous les éléments et on dit
quand même ce serait plus qu'à même
mieux d'annexer la clé usb à lenquête
sans reprendre tous les éléments je
pourrais multiplier des exemples comme
ceux ci j'entends des choses qui sont
pertinentes mais qui me paraissent tout
être des questions de nature
réglementaire et ça c'est un peu la
limite de l'exercice pour le parlement
sega nous pouvons être un outil
d'influencé de d'avoir une fonction de
porte-parole mais notre terrain d'action
c'est législatif est pas le
réglementaire
donc si notre président l'acceptent je
vous renouvelle ma demande de
communication de vos propositions je
retire ma corbeille ma caisse en nous
permettant de en particulier de bien
mesurer quelles sont vos attentes
législatives et quelles sont vos
attentes de nature réglementaire à
charge par nous de trouver le point de
levier dans la discussion avec le garde
des sceaux avec le ministre de
l'intérieur pour essayer quand même pour
ne pas nous désintéresser de ski du
réglementaire vous vous en doutez pas ce
qu'on subodore que c'est bien là où ou
sans l'eau ou le principal de de vos
soucis sans reprendre les questions de
l'informatique dont on mesure bien
l'importance
donc ce sont vous fera passer la
commission vous enverra par mail
cette demande de manière à ce que piché
nous répondre dans un délai qui n'est
pas demain mais qui est le plus heureux
avant l'été ce serait bien avant quand
je dis avant l'été c'est un courant du
mois de juillet serait parfait puisque
la commission travaille les rapporteurs
sont au travail sur le texte
ça nous permettra d'expertisé avant
d'arriver à la période du mois de
septembre où il y aura le rapport et le
séance des questions c'est pas la
question on va on va lever notre
audition mais je voudrais terminer en
m'assurant que en tous les cas pour ce
qui me concerne je comprends bien ce que
vous dites
il ya donc un aspect que j'appellerais
ressources humaines de gestion
ressources humaines et de moyens
matériels qui est prégnant on l'a
entendu il y a un aspect procédure
pénale au sens strict avec un objectif
d'allègement tous les cas de
simplification sont pour autant que les
droits des uns sera respectée mais
comprend bien que la complexité
aujourd'hui de la procédure il y a un
aspect quantum de peine pour les
infractions commises à l'égard
singulièrement des policiers ou toute
personne ayant autorité publique mer
enfin élu plus exactement pompiers ou
autre on sent bien que il me demande il
ya une volonté de d'augmenter la peine
encourue
c'est ce que je crois comprendre
indépendamment du fait du troisième fois
qu'ils aient le prononcé de la peine du
ca parait assez assez clair et enfin de
l'exécution de celle ci avec une
exécution qui sont une exécution rapide
on comprend bien et ça c'est
parfaitement légitime et nous souhaitons
par ailleurs est-ce que ce résumé est
extrêmement simple traduit votre votre
pensée à vous toutes et vous tous dans
la problématique qui est la vôtre
aujourd'hui qui manifestement un pose
problème naturellement on comprend bien
et créer un conflit avec le monde
judiciaire pour être tout à fait clair
aussi ce qu'il faut vous faut dire les
choses si on veut que les choses
avancent il faut qu on les pousse sur
les méthodes allez bordeaux lors du
prime statistiques moi je pense qu'il
est absolument essentiel dans l'analyse
des situations à la compréhension des
situations d'un naturellement les bonnes
réponses à apporter aux gens mais tu vas
te le racing club et si je puis me
permettre
vous avez oublié un point essentiel mais
bon qui n'est pas un oubli re mon avis
mais qui qui qui qui que vous allez
rappeler très justement ces principes de
deux des policiers qui sont allés
justement attaqué et répond p6 bray et
de répondre bien évidemment à cette
problématique car si aujourd'hui on peut
s'attaquer injustement un policier vous
imaginez bien elle commence c'est plus
facile de s'attaquer un citoyen d'où
cette problématique de délinquance qu'on
constate une augmentation augmentation
de la délinquance sur les coûts élevés
sur mon père de des citoyens de ce pays
et ce qui va là pour les citoyens je le
rappelle est valable malheureusement
pour les policiers mais pour les élus et
l'on constate tous les jours donc ça
c'est aussi je tiens à le rappeler un
point essentiel de trouver une solution
à cette problématique de protéger les
forces de l'ordre de ce pays
alors qu'on l'a fait on a trouvé une
voie et permettez moi d'être un tout
petit peu long mais je les ai je vais
aller assez vite quand même la voix s p
de répondre parce que vous venez de
citer
l'observatoire de la réponse pénale pour
dire voilà constat mais aprilia des
réponses ça parce que nous constat et la
réalité on la connaît et vous vous la
connaissez aussi on peut être des
personnages publics
avec des responsabilités publiques
importante c'est que abandonné va
falloir y répondre et la seule réponse
qu'on peut trouver aujourd'hui au vu de
cet échéancier alors sauf quand le chef
de l'état bonds est injustement là aussi
agressé la réponse a été forte pour ce
qui s'est passé on l'a tous vu tous
constaté bon l'individu concerné et je
rappelle que c'est
forte heureusement légitime la sanction
il y a eu un mandat de dépôt aujourd'hui
trouvez moi un exemple où un policier a
été giflée et que l'agresseur a eu un
mandat de dépôt ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui pas un seul exemple on peut
nous donner
on peut pas de donner un seul exemple où
un policier a été giflée et que
l'individu s'est retrouvé un mandat de
dépôt interdiction de droits civiques et
encore quelques caisses qui a encore eu
et de se présenter la fonction est de se
présenter à la fonction publique donc
des faits qui sont légitimes et fort
heureusement parce qu'on a great pas un
président de la république non agréé ce
pas non plus un policier et quand on est
capable de d'imposer parce que là on
voit bien que les magistrats quand ils
veulent ils peuvent et donc dès
l'instant où on peut pour un président
de la république
on peut aussi pour ceux qui représentent
la république par le mandat dont vous
êtes est délégataire
c'est à dire les forces de l'ordre donc
ça c'est important parce qu'il me semble
que c'est un point et c'était un point
essentiel de notre manifestation par
rapport à l'actualité mais c'était pas
nouveau malheureusement et d'où la nôtre
nos revendications communes je rappelle
qu'ils étaient
la peine minimale contre ceux qui
agressent les policiers donc je voulais
pas je pourrai pas me permettre de dire
de recadrer parce que vous avez raison
sur certains points ils sont légitimes
sur ce que vous avez évoquées mais il ne
faut surtout pas oublier un des points
essentiels qui est la protection des
forces de l'ordre
merci monsieur lagache je vais quand
même reprendre la parole pour soi je me
suis mal exprimé je n'ai pas été bien
compris mais quand je dis que vous
voulez revoir le quantum des peines
c'est bien cet aspect là que j'aborde et
quand je dis qu'il faut une réponse
pénale qui soit au niveau c'est bien cet
aspect là que j'aborde il n'y a pas de
doute là-dessus les choses sont
parfaitement claires et on est
parfaitement conscient de la situation
donc ya pas de volonté de ne pas le dire
et à simplement le fait de l'ex pré
peut-être un peu différemment de ce que
vous venez de faire mais c'est bien la
même chose je le rappelais et j'ai bien
si tu es si je dois leur dire à la fois
les actions contre les policiers
mais contre les pompiers ou toutes
personnes incarnant l'autorité sommes
bien clair monsieur ya une autre demande
de parole j'ai vu à brac cité lever tout
à l'heure oui allez y messieurs et
monsieur me reprend globalement vous
avez fait un résumé assez complet de
ciel fut un 10 ou en tout cas de peut
être attendu ben nous on tient
effectivement beaucoup la protection des
policiers des policiers victimes
évidemment ça passe sans la protection
fonctionnelle un qui est d'ailleurs
souvent et contesté de manière assez ni
latéral de par notre illustration
et puis il ya la participation à l'aide
publique à la protection fonctionnelle
c'est tout un ensemble et quelquefois
c'est simplement une épaule a récemment
quand nos collègues de viry châtillon
sont allés l'emporter 6 d'appel ils sont
allés seuls a pas un seul responsable de
leur administration était à leurs côtés
alors que l'époque du drame ils étaient
tous face caméra ou dans les services à
se montrer le solidaire et blessé par ce
qui s'était passé à sont des choses qui
impacte nos collègues et qui peuvent
perdurer
et puis aussi évidemment la protection
des collègues mises en cause qui très
souvent son lot ils ne profitent pas de
la même présomption d'innocence que le
foot à chacun qui souvent sont lâchés
par leur institution
comme si ces faits sont souvent le fait
de d'argent à l'occasion de leurs
services eh ben ça impacte forcément
lors professionnel et très personnelle
est ministre on veut c'est que tant que
je faisais pas de juger à nos collègues
soient pas maltraités de l'institution
merci monsieur ou madame monsieur mon
ouïe très très rapidement parce que le
sujet était quand même général sur les
difficultés rencontrées
il ne faut pas oublier un certain nombre
de sujets qui sont traités dans le cadre
du beauvau je pense à l'encadrement et à
la formation qui n'ont pas disparu qui
sont des sujets importants très
brièvement l'encadrement dans la
gendarmerie nationale il ya un seul
corps de cadres dans la police il y en a
deux on pense qu'il faudrait les unifier
du coup est arrivé à un système où comme
dans la gendarmerie
finalement on commence lieutenant en
commandant une unité sur le terrain pour
parvenir ensuite aux plus hautes
responsabilités
c'est quelque chose qu'on expose au
ministère de l'intérieur dont il est
question depuis longtemps peut-être le
bobo sera-t-il ou pas on verra
l'occasion de faire avancer ce dossier
et puis sur la formation le président de
la république a annoncé récemment dans
un déplacement à montpellier
la création du nord il avait dit une
école de guerre pour la police nationale
donc on attend d'en savoir un petit peu
plus aussi et de préciser les contours
de cette annonce
concrètement pour nos collègues si ça
permet d'avoir davantage de formations
partagé notamment entre les différents
corps ça quelque chose d'intéressant on
y sera évidemment attentif parce que
c'est aussi un point qui est primordial
pour préparer nos futurs collègues à
leur mission
merci monsieur écouter me reste à vous
remercier de votre disponibilité vous
dire que contestable le mans les
rapporteurs du texte confiance dans la
justice ont l'occasion de revenir vers
vous vous après sera rapidement un petit
courrier pour vous confirmer notre
souhait d'avoir aux propositions
notamment en matière de procédure pénale
et puis de tous types en toute hypothèse
nous aurons l'occasion de reprendre
contact
[Musique]